Yeah. Three, two,
Youngstown the house. How are
you brother? Good. How you doing?
Thanks for doing this man. I appreciate
it. No, thanks for having me on.
I appreciate it. You were out here.
I'm working with Danny Garcia,
[inaudible] Garcia, Mikey
Garcia and Garcia camp. Um,
oh. So I came out, you know, a couple
of things. Uh, as we mentioned earlier,
a buddy of mine,
uh,
mark with Micah told us some ideas around
and Kinda just taking a week out here
in California to, you know, keep moving.
It's nice, right? Yeah, it is. Yeah. Yeah,
it was nice. And uh,
Ohio, believe it or not.
And then this morning they woke
up to like three inches of snow,
so I'm out here enjoying
and they got the snow. Well,
the thing about La is no one's from here,
so everybody grew up in a place like
Youngstown or something like that.
Like you were saying, you're running into
a bunch of Youngstown people out here.
Tony Hinchcliffe got super excited to
see you. Absolutely. And I'm a, you know,
that's what's weird about that.
I'm excited to see him and he's
excited to see me and this, uh,
it was really cool. Um, you
know, I've heard of Tony and
I knew of Tony, you know,
before and everything,
and then to finally be able to meet them
and somebody from Youngstown as doing,
you know, great things. It
was Kinda cool. So yeah. No,
it was cool hanging out with you
when we were in Columbus too.
That was a fun time. I was,
I was good eating stew. Yeah.
What was the name of that place again?
You guys picked it,
I believe in Italian market. I
think it was joint. Was that,
is that it was your friend's friend of
a friend of Mike Brown's friend, right?
I don't remember the name. Matthew
Morrel another good guy. Yeah. No, he's,
he's a fucking scary dude.
Just savage.
I got to tell you a funny story with him.
We're at my gym and he came and did
a seminar at my gym and uh, it was,
I have just a fitness gym right now there.
And he was going over and he was
showing people when he kinda came in.
And I was showing him like a little
punch in a hook and he started doing the
elbow off the hook. Now I'm a pretty
big guy and now since I retired and um,
you know,
and I'm working on losing the weight but
he hit me with that elbow on my arm and
it just hurt and it was slow motion.
He wasn't throwing it hard and I'm
going to at this son of a bitch,
really wanted to turn that over. I
wouldn't want to get hit by it. Yeah,
elbows are awful. Bones
are awful. It's like,
it always weirds me out that the UFC
has little padding on the gloves but
there's no padding in your shins.
No padding on your elbows,
no padding on your knees to
terrible way to take a beating.
It is and people get into the brutality
of it. Unfortunate not cause I boxed.
I think box is more brutal.
Only reason is because if you get dropped
in boxing and you got 10 seconds to
get up,
your brand could be rattled in the first
round and you can get dropped four more
times than not fight. You got 36 minutes
of fighting, unfortunately in MMA. Yeah.
They were hitting you with the knees,
the elbows. And if you go down,
they usually stop to fight.
Yeah.
Rightfully so because somebody could
come down with an atomic knee dropping,
you know. I know, but
I'm just saying it's a,
or anything can happen in it.
So when you are fighting a MMA
wasn't as big as it is now,
but did you ever think about doing it?
No. And I'll be honest with, you know, um,
but I was always interested in,
I was,
I was always interested
in the martial arts. Um,
actually that's how I got into boxing
was a young kid taking taekwondo and,
and uh, I don't know that's how
you pronounce it, but it's okay.
And, um, you know, I got into
it with that. It was, to me,
it was kind of like boring.
I'm a young kid,
you know,
I was full of Piss and vinegar and I
wanted to actually get in and do something
and I played other sports.
But, uh, you know, and then
after I retired a little bit,
um, I kind of strayed away from
everything in the fight game and, um,
and I started getting interested
in Jujitsu and stuff like that.
And how old were you when you
retired? 30. 30. That's young. Yeah.
Still am pretty young. How old are you
now? 36. Yeah. You're still in the range?
Yeah, no, it's the effective range. Oh,
that's why I've been working
out and I, you know, I,
I kind of slowed down on the power
lifting a lot and I've been doing,
getting a flexible again.
So you haven't had a fight in six years.
Do you ever get the itch? That's
why I'm saying right now. Yeah.
Yeah. I've been, um,
well another reason why I came out and
we'll talk about what mark and everything,
but, you know, I don't want to leave
nobody ever on either, you know,
this is something you just think I'm
really thinking about it and I'm working
out losing the weight.
But at the same time,
there's a lot of process behind that too.
I would have to sit down with the
family. Um, just go over a lot of things.
You know, you're doing any
boxing these days. Hey,
I've been working out just sitting the
bag pads, stuff like that. Um, you know,
I'm still lifting,
but nothing if you're Jack Dude,
look at the size of your fucking arms.
I know I was up a fight
in middleweight son,
no cruiser weight as to the
Nice area right now. The range.
Yeah. Anybody but USAC and
uh, I'm not fighting nut. That
guy's scary as fuck. Yeah,
I don't, you know, the
thing is everybody, I did,
I've mentioned this a couple of weeks
ago and the first thing that came out
about it was he needed the money
so I can't win for losing. Um,
you know what I mean?
Like,
cause there's other things right now
that we're talking about actually been in
contact believer or not what desks
and with the stars and uh, Jesus,
I'm, I'm having fun with it now.
I guess it don't make no joke.
So I tried to take a fight. I'd
rather fight, use sick, believe me.
It's for the stars is fucking hard work.
Man talks,
talks of it.
Which my buddy Mark's doing,
I've had a couple friends that have been
on that. I said it's brutally hard work.
It is a virtual or teas who was
a fighter. Been on it. Yeah.
So that's where it's going.
Why I don't want people also the
rumor mill will start nut he's broke.
He needs the money because it's
absolutely not the case. Um,
so you retired healthy.
Yeah.
You retired young and you set some
money away but you still look,
you were a world champion for a reason.
You know you had to become
a real world champion.
You have to have some
crazy drive competitive
fire inside you. So there is a, you know,
a lot of people don't understand
in any combat sport callbacks,
combat Umma not pat myself on the back.
I don't know if it's even
good to say but you know,
combat role to champion athletes
and fighter's mentality wise,
you always going to have that mentality,
you know and my only reason why I'm even
throwing this around and I guess that's
the right term to use
because if nothing comes up,
I don't want the backlash on that either.
Because I'm still only 36 and I at that
point where I got that small window
still, you know, where I'm not 40,
I'm not 38 and uh,
you know,
I've been healthy for,
four and a half years and
I've been working out.
And what made you decide to go
power lifting? Just kinda know.
It's telling me US fucking
show bitches whatsoever.
That's another one. Guns. Exactly
right. I was tired and think about it.
I was so damn skinny.
If I turned sideways and stuck my
tongue out of the book a Zipper,
you know what I mean?
Um,
and being six foot 200 and make
it happen to make 160 pounds,
even between fights,
you still had to maintain your weight.
And I got tired of that. Uh, what
was your walking around with?
I'll walk around about one 73.
That's not that bad. No, it's not.
And that's a real light and you
know, and then, but as I got older,
yeah, I started getting a little
more difficult to, you know,
keep that and I started getting
up to like one 75, almost one 80.
So now you're looking at a,
and I'm still skinny at that point.
So now you're looking at it how can to
lose 20 more pounds again to get down at
that age. And it came to a point, um,
which cause a lot of issues for me,
one flight with the Martinez fight and uh,
after that we had to jump out.
Hmm. Yeah. That point of
diminishing returns, right?
When you're just cutting too much weight.
When you fuck Tremaine Taylor,
that was one 60, right? Yes. Yeah, too.
I was one fight where I remember getting
angry at Larry Merchant was Larry
Merchant's calling a
fight. I'm like, he's not,
he's wasn't recognizing that you were
tuning him up and you were hurting him and
he like, he was, he was commenting on a,
almost like it was a trend
that he expected to see
rather than what was actually
happening.
It was a lot of things about that fight.
I loved them guys because
believe it or not, in my opinion,
that was a great fight.
And I seen that day had that fight
and a top 10 middle weight, uh,
one of the top 10 middle way fights of
all time. And that's kind of a cool thing.
But also, you know, some of that
commentating, no really made that fight,
especially at the end in my opinion,
made that flight kind of what it was also,
you know, besides the fact that me
getting dropped and everything, but um,
I didn't agree with the judging of it,
you know, cause I still had me ahead.
I went back and wash it.
I'm not one of those egotistical people
use or like I like to really break down
what happened in that fight and I,
and if I lost a round,
I would say I lost around, you know,
I was hard on myself with that.
I watched that fight and I'll probably
10 times and I don't see where they
had remained winning, you know? Yeah. I
gave him one round and plus the 10, eight.
So as a total of three rounds and,
uh, I don't see how that happened.
Well, you know, I mean we,
we've had this conversation a
hundred times in this podcast,
but judging and boxing and judging
in MMA judging is just terrible.
It's just terrible. It's sad.
It doesn't make any sense.
There's so many experts out there.
There's so many really reliable people
that you can call on that would do a
great job of, of, of figuring
out what's going on in a fight.
And for whatever reason,
they don't get those jobs.
I think they gotta start doing something
soon. Inbox and what that, yeah.
They have to figure something out.
What the judging Charlo fight. Yes.
Yeah.
There's a handful of people I had the
argument with that actually thought
Charlotte lost.
Um,
I didn't think that he looked as good
as he could have enough flight. Yeah.
But I thought he wanted to fight,
you know, um, one 16, one 12. Uh,
but I don't know what system they could
try to break down for that or tried to
get to actually start making
some of them fights fair.
But boxing is doing fantastic to pass
two years. I mean the numbers are crazy.
You seem what does zone? There were
Canelo and yeah, so it's, it's there.
Just the attention is that the sport
and the popularity of it's coming back,
but what could eventually hurt it
again is things like the judging of the
flights. Yeah. Outcomes. Well
there's certain ones where you,
you want to like you want a criminal
investigation like Tim Bradley,
Manny Pacquiao. That was one where
after that was up I was like,
I was looking at the TV,
I was looking to the side.
I was looking at where I was like,
what the fuck did I just see
what just happened here? Okay.
Okay.
That flight rate there, I actually
had to walk away with my head down.
I that that was probably one of the
worst robberies that I've ever seen.
It was horrible robbery.
I searched to give Tim Bradley two rounds.
I gave him one. I was trying to give
him rounds there. Kyle Lake say, how?
Where did you get to set in other words
and I couldn't do it. Yeah, I loved him.
Bradley too, by the way. Awesome
guy. Awesome. Awesome fighter too.
I mean he's just all hard. I
mean the guy's, he's amazing.
But that just was a bad decision.
And you know,
I think there was a,
there was a lady that was responsible
for two really bad decisions. That word?
Yeah, to lady bird. Was it her?
Was it? There was another one too.
There was an adult bird. She does have
a May two I want to say. Ah, yeah.
Ladder. Letterman's daughter
baby. Well there was no,
there was another lady who retired
from doing it after that decision.
It was like a big controversy. People
were her, her score was so off.
People were thinking she got paid
off just so many anymore though.
It's hard to keep up with
it. Well, the thing is,
and people that are cynical or skeptical,
do you know how much money
is being bet on fights?
Especially a Manny Pacquiao fight.
There's so much money.
And if someone like packing,
I was a prohibitive favorite heading
to 10 proudly fight. I mean, who knows?
It could be four to one five, two, one
six, two, one. Somebody rolls up with
a Nice Brown bag, you
fill it. We got in here,
here's $30,000 I never have
to report. I think just, yeah,
there was more behind
why that happens to be.
That's always been the idea that there's
no bribery going on anymore. It's crazy.
I don't want to say it, but
I think I have, yeah, I think
I have an idea. You know,
I think it comes down to
who's putting the show on
[inaudible] and who's who's in the pocket.
But Teddy Atlas was explaining
it to when he was on the podcast.
One of the things that he was saying
was that they take these people out to
dinner,
like the,
like they're all in cahoots and friendly
with each other and if there's a
certain result that the
promoter would like to see,
these judges will lean towards that if
they have a good relationship with that
promoter. You said it for me. Yeah.
That's what it is. Look, teddy laid it out
and um, I don't know. Yeah, it's bad
because again, boxes really coming back.
It is and the fights, you got three
or four weight classes right now.
That's so interesting.
But the bad part about it is you don't
get interested in it or you don't get as
excited anymore because you're
afraid of the outcome of that.
Yeah.
You know,
I wasn't terribly upset at
the wilder fury decision.
I wasn't terribly upset. I
thought, I thought, you know what?
I think Tyson fury did enough to win.
But when I look at it,
I like when I like when they scored
damage damage means a lot to me.
And when I look at that fight,
when, when wild or hurt him,
he heard him twice and
he heard him real bad.
I mean I think that's worth a lot and
I think he was always threatening.
So I felt like,
I don't know if I would agree with a draw.
I think it was a close decision when
for Tyson fury, but I didn't hate it.
I didn't hate it cause I think I'd like
to see them fight again. Absolutely.
I mean it was one of them fights
where yes,
you're 100% right.
That it could have been a draw and I
think everybody would be kind of satisfied
with that. Yeah. Um, unfortunately
with the account and knocked down,
which I was so frustrated with
the comments and you know,
I had to stay away from the social
media and the boxing groups and,
and things like that because, oh,
just, you know, to some of the
opinions of people as the
way to put it. Uh, well deaf,
that was a long count and this and that.
There has been thousands of fights in
the last 10 years and I've very solid
heard anybody complain about account,
you know, that, that fight. Um,
they don't do a ten second count unboxing
and he'd go by the referees count and
for another thing,
we're a wilder kind of hurt himself.
Referee tells you in the locker room
before the flight and he explains it to go
to your neutral corner.
If you come out of your neutral corner,
I will stop the account
mean you know that.
So the first thing I used to do it when
I dropped somebody is I ran my ass to
that neutral corner. You know, said I
worked for, we can start counting. Um,
I didn't see any issue with the, the
knockdown, I even recorded it on my phone.
And if you did go by the ten second count,
Tyson fury still beat it. Really? Yes,
I have it. You know, I'd have
to go through and find it. Um,
I thought I saw it on a
Instagram or one of them. It was,
I think it was on Wilders Instagram where
he had it, where worthy count starts.
Right when fewer drops.
I counted it as soon as his back almost
right before his back kits to ground
until where he got up.
And again,
that's only a ten second count without a
referee even come on over to, you know.
Okay. Um, but you know, as
far as the, the fight itself,
I gave,
I gave Walter obviously the two knock
downs that's automatically four rounds.
But I thought,
and I gave him one other round after that.
I thought Tyson fairy
controlled the action. You know,
I had controlled the momentum of
the fight. On the flip side of it,
I think that water actually could've
made that an easier fight to, you know,
water actually has a hard time.
What is control and he don't know
how to really work to the body.
I don't want to put it on a trainer.
I don't know what the issue is with that.
But he neglected that body
a lot throughout the flight.
And I just thought that's why Tyson
when most of those rounds, you know,
he just controlled the action to pace
and was kind of able to do what he wanted
to.
And I think that if Walter went backward,
his trainer and watched
the tape would have light,
they're going to see a lot
of opportunities that were
missed enough light. Well,
you know what's crazy about wilder is how
little time he's actually been boxing.
I mean it's really stunning.
When he was on here,
he told us that he made the Olympic
team a year and a half into war learning
boxing. Yeah. And he won a bronze medal
in the heavyweight division though.
You can kind of get away with
that too. Yeah, you can. You know,
most of your heavy for, well back
then also we're big guys who came up.
Usually most of them were football
players or something like that.
And they kind of just got into the sport
and still even to this day you were
talking about maybe three heavyweights
that really could throw it down. Um,
as were some of the other guys are just
big sloppy guys that come in, you know.
So what do we got now? You
got Luis Ortiz, you got fury,
you wilder. Josh. Joshua. Who
else? Joseph Parker. Yeah.
Parker Parker is one of the guys that
could actually still upset anybody in the
heavyweight division, especially
with that style that he has. Um,
so it's getting interesting again
though. It is. It's certainly,
well I think with wilder and fury,
that was one of the more interesting
heavyweight title fights in a long time.
And while there's so, it's
so weird. He's so different.
He weighs 209 pounds. He's
skinny as a rail. He hits you.
It looks like you get hit in
the face with a missile. I mean,
it's crazy cause that is a missile
he's firing. Fuck, you know,
crazy power that guy and I tried to
explain to people when I tell you,
you don't have to be a big guy. Yeah.
You know, it's all about the leverage,
how he did torque. Uh, where are you,
how you generate that power and no,
he's just one of them guys that that's
one of the things were you either have it,
yeah,
you got it in the cradle or you don't.
And that's another one that you tried
to explain. And even like in baseball,
you're either a home run
hitter or you're not, you know,
you could on a little bit and
maybe knock one or two more home runs
out or knock a guy or two out more.
But if you don't have,
you're not going to,
unless you really go back over and find
the time and patience to reprogram that
fighter and change the whole style.
Yeah.
It feels like one punch knockout power.
You either have or you don't and,
but the, the guys who can put it
on you and stop you like Julio.
Cesar Chavez never had really
that one punch knockout power,
but he fucked a lot of people up and
he had a body shot too. He did not,
he didn't need a knock
out punch to the head too.
He was so perfect when
he was in his prime.
The way he would fight was constant
bobbing, weaving, moving in,
and then once he put that pace on you,
it was just constant damage,
constant punch to the volume,
the volume to accuracy and the
fact that he never got tired,
he would just keep that pace
up. Pap Pap, pap, pap pap,
and you'd see guys just start to wilt.
Just backing up all the time.
Just wilt under that pressure.
Then as that body attack that he had,
how he invested into that body from the
early rounds, people carry those punches.
You know, they carried out into the
fifth and six round and it was brutal.
You know, I couldn't imagine a fight and
I fly some tough guys, but I was glad,
you know, being a tall guy that nobody
ever went to the body like that.
I guess me, I would've hated that. It's a,
it's fucking rough way to make a living,
bro. There is Chavez in his prime.
God Damn was good. Ooh.
It was so good. I mean,
it's just constant movement to constant
cutting angles and the fucking pressure.
Another one like him was Duran too.
That's Roger Mayweather, right? Yes. Yeah.
Black Mamba. Yeah. People
forgot about Roger.
He just systematically broke
you down. Chavez. Yeah.
Very tactical and textbook
and it make many mistakes.
It wasn't flashy. He wasn't overly
fast. He wasn't overly powerful.
But he just broke you down the right
way and to the right punches. Yeah,
that's what, that's the best way to
put it. Through the right punches.
He was just relentless and he
was constantly moving forward.
Constant pressure. God Damn. He was good.
Yup. And you know, uh Oh Greg Halligan.
Oh,
remember that one Greg Hogan said he
found a bunch of Tijuana taxi drivers and
he'd beat the shit out of break out
those those left hooks the body.
But just like tough taxi
drivers, young fighters, man,
you want to like emulate a guy who
just fought with perfect technique.
This is the guy.
Well you know that comes down to
another thing that I was breaking down.
I actually,
I touched on it on my show a lot and a
lot of people get mixed up and confused
on a fact of foot work.
What people and some of the guys
that had the best footwork in boxing,
we're not flashy guys with the footwork
or even like Mikey Garcia now or like a
a Bernard Hopkins is another one.
But you had guys pronounce a word occur.
I know I'm going to probably get beat up
on this. He, he, he had decent footwork.
What I mean by that because,
because yeah, he make you miss.
But Brunel would occur a lot of times,
put himself out of range
by moving lake that, you know, he
make that move or he'd do it too much.
And then he wasn't there to
counter. So what good did it do? A,
you get guys like Chavez or Duran or a
guys like Mikey Garcia now they take that
one little step inches and angles.
They take that one step and earn
brightened position for that punch.
They take the opposite step to suffocate
your punch, you know, and throw you off.
They spin you around, you know,
that's where footwear comes in.
And Chavez was great at that.
Yeah. Um, he was always in range. He
was always in range. He was never,
never running away. And Yeah.
Yeah. And his like, you know,
the guy who does it the best today
about cutting angles and being bright in
front of you, you can't him
is Luma Chanko oof. I mean,
Loma Chanko stands right in
front of you and then he's not,
and then he's over here and he's
punching you in the face. Tj Dillashaw,
who's a UFC bantamweight champion,
said he's sparred with him.
And he said the first round was like,
you know,
Lomas Shankles just feeling them up,
just figuring them out and you know,
he's like, no, I'm kind of
hanging in there with this guy.
And then his dad yelled
something in Russian and then
the second round Loma Cenk
goes just dancing around him,
stepping to the side, touching them
Zoe round they put on youtube
too. You know what I mean?
Um, yeah, I see. You know,
the thing with Lowman Chanko is this,
uh,
and I tell people also
like Floyd Mayweather was,
is unbelievable defensive fighter. But
Floyd was really good on drawing you in,
you know,
and kind of countering off that his
defense and his reflexes were amazing,
but he kind of lured you in a
little bit, made you miss, make,
made you make a mistake,
and then he would counter you.
Loma Chanko on the other hand,
as a guy,
you could throw a punch and f punched
could be emitter and he's spinning and
he's already behind you. Yeah, it's
a, the athleticism is astonishing.
I have not seen it. Uh, granted, can
he lose? Absolutely. It's boxing.
And if you get one of them rugged guys
that are just going to come in and say,
you know what, screw it, I'm going
to, I'm just going to get hit,
but I'm going to hit him. That may be a
type of fighter that beats Alma Chanko.
Okay,
well, well who was it that was it the
Mexican guy who beat him? Uh, in uh,
one of his first fight.
Oh, uh, Selise Salito
Salito right, right, right.
Yeah. That was the kind of fight that
he fought. His dirty got on top of him.
But you got to understand
on that point too,
that was Loma Chanko second pro fight
and I guess a real veteran guy who's been
there and done it and seen it.
And that's the argument and
it's hard to explain again.
And that was another argument on,
he's a dag is a little frustrated reading
second pro fight and usually in boxing
and it goes like the first
year you're up for six,
second year he may be,
you start getting up to eight,
but you get a good amount of fights
under your belt before you start getting
into the 10 rounds and
12 rounds. Okay. Um,
you're talking about a kid coming
out of the amateurs fighting three,
three minute rounds are for two minute
rounds depending on whatever tournament
or international it is. And he's going
right into a Charl 12 round fight.
I know my myself coming up and the
process that top rung brought me up,
which was a great process to,
they've had,
they pick the fights and they made sure
that if ice that they pick for me where
to correct flights and a Gruen
me the right way, you know,
by rounds and everything else.
And I know just jumping from six to eight,
the difference in that,
you know,
let alone being a kid and you're going
into your second pro fight and you're
fighting a 12 round fight.
So if he lost that fight,
which he came back and he
made it a really close fight,
I would have to tip my hat to him just
on the fact that he was able to go 12
rounds, you know, um, people take
a lot away from, from that fighter.
What he accomplished is something
that not many can do. Well,
it's crazy mean he had a
second protitle at what,
how many fights in the second fight was
for the role title that he wanted to
roll side on his dirt profile.
Yeah, that's insane. And then,
but he's had more than one per
world title, right? Yes. He,
he's won a could three different ways
classes, but his second one was something
insane. Some insanely short seat.
Pull up his record. Yeah. I believe
Tom Bradley. I looked at the source.
What's that?
It says his first fight was for the
international featherweight title that was
against Salito Ramirez. He said, Oh,
you lost against Lido for the vacant
Wbo featherweight title. Oh, okay.
So what was the first title? International
featherweight title. Wbo Yeah,
that's not a real, that's not
like a world title. This is,
they have a bunch of weird titles,
right? Like international title,
continental title. You're
assaulting me. I had to do an IPO.
I had to deal with the world champion.
But you had all of it. You are unified.
I should have been by all rights. But
Taylor vacated to Oh, that's right.
But he, you know, that's why I get
mad. And that's another big argument.
And boxing how you break
that down between the lineal,
the lineal and a unanimous, you
know, I had to ring the Wbo scroll,
Scroll up. So you see his homework.
So what was his, uh, okay.
So his second world title was
when routined retained one.
Okay. One, two, three,
four, five, six flights in.
He's in his second. He's um, he, that's
when he, he, he wins his second title.
Six fights in each one's a junior
lightweight title. That's insane.
The International, okay. That wasn't the
first one. Wasn't a world title fight.
It was the right with the second one
was the Wbo world title fight 11 fights.
Any wins is third world title.
What in the fuck I believe now there
was at one point it was seven rural
champions and just that short period of
fights, I believe it's around eight now,
eight real champions,
these flat and just that short period,
a three different weight classes.
I think when he fought were gone d out,
you really got a chance to see
how he handles a real world class,
you know,
Cuban amateur system trained top of
the food chain boxer and he
just put it to that dude.
That was the fight that I actually
really sold me on [inaudible] because I
thought for a fact that that was going
to be a chess match because of the boxing
ability from rigging dollar. Their styles
were very similar and I thought that,
you know,
I was like,
it's going to be a boring fight
for the first like four rounds,
which I still would have liked because
I like watching that type of fights,
you know? And um, I see. I go in there
and I'm expecting this fight, you know,
the,
the amateur background of both guys,
the how talented the guys are
in a skill level of both guys.
And then mixing, I know I'm two or
three rounds into it and I'm going,
he's playing what? We're no playing
with them. I'm going to hell.
That's the fight that really sold me
on Loma Chanko that he's that good.
My Man Vinny pass the ends are called
that not Vinny Pazienza, the boxer,
Vinnie pads, the rapper, this guy, Jedi
mind tricks he called and he was taking,
he was taking bets on Instagram.
Jeez. He called it that early too.
He was taking bets on Instagram. You
think [inaudible] has anything for him?
He's like five, 5 million, the
DMS. And he goes, let's bet. Yup.
I uh,
I took Loma Chanko and that flight,
but I thought it was going to be a
close fight, a really close fight.
And I thought Loma Chanko was going to
pull ahead in the later rounds, you know,
and when that fight.
So that's why I really surprised me.
It was a stunning display of talent.
He such a weird guy too because uh,
his background,
you know,
the store where his father took him out
of boxing and made him do traditional
Russian dancing for several years and
just made him learn that for footwork.
It seems like his dad was just a
mastermind architect of a champion. Yeah.
You would probably know more than this.
The Nub would,
didn't he also have a more
short background? I heard, uh,
he definitely can do martial
arts techniques. I've seen
it, but I don't know what
background maybe, I don't
know. That makes sense. He's a,
his foot work though is so extraordinary
and if that really is that dancing
background, like learning the,
the footwork and the, the way he,
he's so agile with the stepping
of his feet. It's like,
I think a lot of people are going
to learn and mirror that. Yeah.
His training regimen is pretty brutal.
Also, I got a buddy, a Roger Romo, um,
good friend of mine.
He's actually,
he was working for a little while
there up until the last fight.
He was a strength and conditioning
coach would Cecilio Flores,
who was mine when I was an
Ochsner training and they
said it was just crazy that
the hours that he puts in,
how he trains,
how hard he trains and some of the
journals study does. You know, I,
I'm looking at them and going,
I could use these, not for me,
but I could use them for somebody
athletes that I got now. Yeah. He's, um,
he's definitely something special and you
know, you get those guys and it's just,
it's kind of ashamed that he's a
little too small for Terrence Crawford,
you know? I mean, I really would
love to see those two fight,
but it seems like Crawford just a
little bit too heavy for him. I agree.
But that's uh, you know, and that's
another touchy subject because I kind
of agree with you,
but I also go back,
cause I'm always trying to
really break down and nitpick.
I look at guys like Manny
Pacquiao [inaudible] who was it,
who came from I believe one
12 or something like that,
and went up all the way to
junior middleweight, which
is crazy. Yeah, he's small.
Shorter than than Lowman Shanker.
Yeah. And other than his calves.
And I don't think anything else was much
bigger than Lowman Chanko on his body
and he was able to do it. And what
the fuck is going on with his calves?
I don't know. It's like he's keeping Hams
in them. I don't know what he does. I,
you know, I wish I knew to secret
today cause I could use it.
So get that secret to Jon Jones article
says that his mother was actually a
martial arts, still is a martial
artist. Oh, interesting. Hmm. Gymnast.
The martial artist.
Well it makes sense.
Yeah. Man. Foot work the way he does
it. It's just, it's something to watch,
man. It's just the, the,
the ability to do move and also to
anticipate the other fighters movements.
It's like,
especially earlier in his career,
it's like he was fighting guys that just,
they seemed so
crude in comparison to his approach.
He knows even more crazy about it as
being the opponent because usually you go
into a fight and you break
down film and you're,
you're going over to film and you got
a good idea of what he does, right.
What he does wrong and,
and what you might have to do launch
Chanko it's hard to pick up where he's
going to go. He'd be different angles.
So you can't, you can't go well,
you know what?
After he throws the right hand,
he likes to move over to the left because
he does at one time and then the next
time he's totally something we're
opposite. You know what I mean? And yeah,
the angles, it's really almost impossible
to break film down on them. You know,
like this last fight with just per draws,
everybody's going.
That was the blueprint. No, no, no.
It wasn't. So, you know, he, uh,
interstate and it was a close to fight
then, you know, people expect expected.
I go, why? Because he finally got hit
with more than 11 punches in a fight. Oh,
that's him doing some,
uh, I'd be like, yeah,
he says trained it when he
was a younger Greco Roman.
Yeah. Yeah. He's, he's slamming
kids. That's right. Well,
you know what man,
I believe in cross training and I think
that there's certainly some skills that
would make you better at
different martial arts. And uh,
I feel like if you have the
ability to wrestle guys and,
and move guys' bodies around like that
you would get from something like samba.
I just feel like as a an elite boxer,
having that extra strength,
that extra ability to move your core that
way, I think that would be beneficial.
Yeah.
I mean the thing is no worldclass boxer
has the time to also be doing judo and
also be doing wrestling.
You just don't have the time.
Nope. And then being in combat
sports, even, I know that as far as,
I'm not involved in MMA, but I
know that, you know, these guys,
they have a perfect three or four as
much time in a short period of time.
You know, I imagine, I think Matt was
telling me you would know more. Like,
sometimes it's two days of
one, two days of the next. Um,
trying to fit that in.
Yeah, it's hard. You cannot,
especially in boxing the sweet science
where it's just hands, but you got
people, that's all he do all day long.
That's why I say it's so unfair when
an MMA guy goes in fights of Mayweather
because Mayweather,
he perfected that and you gotta
use just that style of boxing.
It's going to be almost impossible to
beat a boxer, a rural champion boxer.
Did you watch the new year's fight,
that thing that he did with the attention?
Yes. You Cower. Yeah. Yeah. A lot of
people think that was a fixed fight.
I think that was 120 pound fighter
fighting the best ever. Yeah.
I mean it's just,
it wasn't a fixed fight.
I don't know why people think it's a fixed
fight. That guy fights it 126 pounds,
I think. Yeah. I think
that's his weight class.
And you could definitely
tell the size difference.
Just like I could actually tell the size
difference stolen McGregor fight, Floyd,
you know, I think uh, both of his
legs equal to one of Mcgregor's,
but yeah, that tension, that fight
the first knocked down was legit.
And I think, my personal
opinion, what happened, it wasn't
fixed, you know, are fake.
I believe that he got hit with that right
hand and it seemed that how strong and
how to deep fence the skills that a
Mayweather had. And I think he said,
you know what,
this could be a long ass night.
And then the next couple of punches he
just kinda like went down because he seen
what could happen. He knew which way
that flight was going. Really? Yeah.
That's what you think. I do the first
knock down. Let's put play that fight,
see if you can find the fight and play it.
I feel like the first one
clipped him on the temple.
He hit him with a left hook on the temple,
hit him with a right hand,
but then he hit him with a left hook,
the right hand,
and then he hit him afterwards
as well as he's going down.
But I think that left hand the temple is
what did the real damage. And then, um,
then there was a big right hand
afterwards that dropped him.
I just think he was out of his league.
He's that way, way out of his league.
Not that he took a dive,
but almost to the point of like,
he knew that that fight was not going
any way. The way that he thought it was.
I mean, he looks, he was so smiley and
relaxed. It was kind of funny. You know,
he just sort of walk the dude down.
He had a big old smile and it tastes
like when they get them smiling.
What was the last time you saw us? And
he's so much bigger than this kid, right?
Yeah. He's fighting like it's
a joke. Like, look at him.
He's so much bigger than this kid.
What's really funny is if they let this
kid kick, he would fuck Floyd up. Yeah.
I feel that I'm Katie Floyd
made it look so dominant.
I didn't even know on that part.
But then again, that kid, his kicks,
that kid would've kicked Floyd's legs
out from under them in seconds. Oh wait,
you went too far there. See He,
he got up right there. Boom. See?
He hit him with a left hook
and he stumbled and then
he hit him with the right
hand behind it. And I just think
he's too little. He's just a,
he's a very small guy and for
him and Floyd's not a big guy.
This kid is tiny.
I mean,
I think he's fought as light as 121
pounds and I think sometimes he fights it
like one 26 yeah, I think he could
see right there, right there.
Sometimes it'll fight.
A lot of times in a fight,
the whole issue is you get hit with that
and you're fighting and somebody taps
you with a certain punch. Your brain.
You'll be surprised how fast it works,
you know, and all the things that go
through it at mind. Boom. That was yep.
And I think at that, that moment
right there, he just knew going in,
you can fill just when somebody hits you
on the arm or the shoulder, you know,
the how, how punch power
they have. And uh, yeah,
I think he's just trying to, after that
he knew I was going to be a long night.
So crazy. They paid him $9
million for this. It must be nice
that, yeah. I mean fuck, there was
a lot of people I seen going, uh,
he deserves to give somebody whose
prospects a a chance now, you know,
he should be fighting these guys instead
of doing this, these guys ain't boxers,
blah, blah, blah, blah. And my take
on that also is the man went 40,
49, 50 and older. He fought
almost everybody in the sport.
And even if you want to say
that they were past her prime,
some of them may have been a little bit,
he's still willing to earn,
dominated them and beat them.
Yeah. This guy, in my opinion,
if he wanted to fight
defensive backs from the NFL,
he has all the right and the roller. I
don't think that he owes a sport anything.
I think actually it's
the other way around.
The amount of money that he
has brought to the sport,
the attention that he brought to it.
So if he wants to go around and duty
side shows, let them, you know, I mean,
what do you want him to do?
Fight prospects until he's 51 years old.
I couldn't agree more. I
couldn't agree more. It's crazy.
The idea that they want to
see him sacrificed. Yeah.
They want to see him get beat.
That's what they want.
They want to see him finally fight someone
who's younger and faster, hungrier,
who was more active. And what
will happen was that he will lose.
And I think maybe what a
smarter than that, you know,
he wants to go out and keep that his
status and, and the, and the, the,
the record that he built up in that
resume that he has and go out like that,
you know? Well, they're talking about him
fighting Khabib number. Good amount off.
Who's the UFC 155 pound champion. But
it can be, it's not really a boxer.
I just want to say it. But boxing rules.
Yeah, he that would be same thing. Yeah.
It could be was a take down
ground type guy. Exactly.
It'd be the same kind of
fight as the Conor fight.
The only difference is I don't think
could be get as tired as Connor would. No,
I don't, I don't think, uh, he's,
he's definitely got better endurance.
I think one of the only
few in there right now.
That would be a good flight would be one
of the Diaz brothers as far as striking
down. Be Interesting. But they
would, he would box her face off.
I still think that he would win that,
but I'm just saying as far as you know,
stand up and letting the hands go.
I think those are one of the,
one of the two better ones in the MMA.
Yeah.
I mean he's got all
the right in the world.
Just keep fine freak shows to have fun,
man.
The only thing is, you know, a
father time shows up, you know,
he's getting to that age where you
might get one of them guys. And so,
I mean if he's having a fun do it.
But if you go and get
beat by one of them guys,
that could change the whole
outlook of a career. Well,
it's interesting how guys who
are really good defensively,
they're not just really good longer
because they have such good technique,
but also they've taken less damaged during
their career so they're more durable
as they get older as well. Like you've
definitely saw that with Bernard,
like Bernard up until
the Joe Smith fight me,
Joe Smith was the first
guy to really put it on.
I'm like that and knock them out of
the ring. And it was hard to see.
It was hard to see that they,
they had that ring set up to where he
fell and landed on his fucking head like
Jesus Christ. You know? I don't
know if there was so much to ring.
I just think it was an awkward way
that he went out of the ropes in a way
because he got hurt by
that punch. Yeah. So,
and the legs buckled and when
the legs buckle like that,
they could put him in an awkward
position for him to slide out. You know,
his ass was headed out and then you get
clipped again and went right through.
But I mean, it just sucks that there's
nothing to protect the fighters.
If they fall out like that.
There's no padding. There's
no, no tables, no nothing,
nothing to break your fall.
No one,
therefore it just got to hope
one of the ringside judges are,
or commentators are there too.
That's crazy.
And you got guys that are 80 years old
trying to push a 200 pound man back in
the ring. Yeah. They're not going to
get clipped like that and wanting to,
somebody's fallen on them.
Um,
but Bernard was able to keep
his skill very late in life.
I mean deep into his forties, almost
a 50 years old was still world class,
which is really crazy. I had is, uh,
you got a handful of guys out there
that could do that and to be honest,
you know,
but he kept himself in good shape in
between fights and he did what he was
supposed to do. And some guys, you
know, you get some guys out there,
a good friend of mine, my trainer
Robert Garcia, retired at 29, um, uh,
Youngstown guy, man. See, he retired young
and came back a couple of years later,
but it was totally for one flight.
Um,
who did Mancy any come back against
Greg Haugen. Oh, that's right.
I forgot about that. Fine. Yup.
And uh, some of them, you know,
some guys they go in and do it and it's,
it's fun and then it becomes a career,
a job and financial security.
You know, the way Pete, a
lot of fighters look at it.
And then you get some guys like
Floyd, Mandy Pack, Yell, uh,
Bernard Hopkins who just loved the sport,
you know that much that does.
They don't know anything
else outside of it.
So what was it like fighting Bernard
who,
you know,
and I don't know if this is the stage
stage I want to fighting Bernard was,
it was, it was, um, totally different
than what I expected. What'd you expect?
I expect him to be tricky and sneaky
and just a very crafty and obviously
experienced.
Um,
I did jump up two weight classes
to take that fight and um,
but at the same time,
that was not an 80% Kelly public.
And this is true and this is documented.
Um, I have it on my phone and I was
going to actually bring that out.
But that flight I sparred three times
for that maybe for the time was with an
arm brace and then went into it and I'd
never said anything cause I'm the type
person, I don't want to have people
think that was making excuses.
I love Bernard and I think
he's, uh, one of the greatest of
all time, greatest middleweights.
But that was not that night. You know, I
came down, we had wrong what was right.
I had bronchitis, I was
sick, I was running a temp
actually in the locker room.
We had to go through what the commission,
um,
we almost took the inhaler for it.
Then we found out through the commission
that you cannot take that cause it's
steroid. So we had to go to the
nasal, um, or not nasal to the pill.
Oral pill. Uh, we had
an in the locker room.
I don't know if you ever heard of
a Guy Thomas houser. He writes you,
he used to write from New York Times.
He does a lot of big box and books.
He was an urn and houser don't, uh,
he's not one side. What's anybody?
He's Bryce. What? He knows what he
sees and that's the truth. And um,
he was in there when
the commission came in.
They were going through my prescription,
you know, they were taking a temperature,
uh, giving me the exam.
And that's what happened.
How it was a look Dardick
fight with, uh, of all people.
What was wrong with your arm? You,
you [inaudible] bursitis, societies,
bursitis in your elbow. And you know,
that came into an issue and we smart.
We know, like I said, it was a handful.
It might've been more than three or four,
but it wasn't a lot because usually in
training camp you do it three days a week
for about eight week camp for about six,
six and a half weeks.
And it was because of your album that
you couldn't spar. Yeah. You know,
cause he didn't want to keep hitting it.
And then I didn't like just the way I am.
I didn't like having a
brace on it or nothing. Um,
so that was an issue and there was a lot
of things that sometimes if you could
go back and you wish you
could do it over again,
but there was a lot of other things going
on. Why we didn't postpone the fight.
First of all is sold out and uh,
the Youngstown people bottle or tickets,
um, we had the issue with
Depaul Williams fight, you know,
that fell through. So I can't, I
just came off light and Gary Lockett,
who was really not of all
known name a household name.
So if I would to postpone that fight,
the backlash on that would have
been bad man. And you know,
so it was more the ego thing I think,
and worried about what
everybody was going to think,
taking nothing away at all from,
and that's where I wanted to tap into
taking nothing away from Bernard Hopkins
unfortunately against a guy like Bernard
Hopkins that had to have that happen to
me is what socks. And, and he
was a tremendous fighter. I mean,
he did things in there.
A lot of times I've seen him making
moves that I knew what he was doing and I
just couldn't pull the trigger on it.
Um, and he was fast and he was strong.
And then there was times that he just did
some crafty things also that, you know,
got to me and his body work in
that fight slowed me down a lot.
But it was just one of them fights where
I could honestly say that that was not
an 80% Kelly Pollick. And that could
be honest and say if I was 100%,
I don't know if I would have won that
fight. And I'll be honest about it.
I'm not going to be the guy that's,
that comes in and says, well,
if I was 100% I would have knocked him
out. No, it's Bernard Hopkins. You know,
when you think about your legacy and you
think about looking back at your career,
those kinds of fights where you had to
take it when you were compromised, um,
how do those factor in to do
those fuck with your head?
Hmm. Yeah, that liberal bad way,
right? But enough where you like, ah,
if I was 100%, yeah. You know,
I got invited to the international boxing
hall of fame over to summer and it was
cool as hell and to be there and you
start seeing the inductees and everything
and I start, you start breaking
down your career. Like, am I,
am I able to qualify for
this? You know, and it's so,
so going to get pissed off who didn't
get in because I got in and I look at it
and I break it down a couple of ways.
I say 40 and two with 34
knockouts is a hell of a record.
You know, I held the belts
for over three years. Um,
I'd be a handful of guys that were
legit when I beat them. And then I,
then I look at the fight though I
fought Bernard Hopkins and I got my ass
whooped in fight and there was no other
way of putting it, you know, the truth.
So how much did that damage? You know, uh,
people remembering that nobody looks at
the fact of the two way class jump and
they call him back down and defending
against a very game. Antonio Rubio.
And then of course the Martinez fight,
which a lot of people,
and it was documented and, and on
Hbo with the commentators, you know,
the weight issue in that fight. But what
was the way it is from that? Fine. Oh,
so how we had to get done. That was my
last fight. At middle weight, you know,
trying to cut the weight. I was 29 at
the time and another great fighter. I,
it happened, it was tough
with the weight. Um,
I really can't use that as an excuse
though, cause I don't know. But you know,
I know I was doing good in the
ninth round. I did hit a wall.
A lot of people would try to use the
cut and I think even without the cut,
the same result would have
happened. Now, you know,
he would have boxed my ears
off the last four rounds.
It was just one of them things that
there's nothing you could do. So when I,
when I have some up my career,
I look at those fights and I,
and I know personally that
it could have been different,
but at the same time I'm very happy and
content with the way my career went.
You know, I was 40 and two, um, my last
four or five, I won my last four fights,
you know, before I retire. So
I went out winning, um, and,
and I was done with the
sport. I truly was. And so I,
I think right now I'm, I'm kind of content
and happy with my career. Of course.
I think anybody says could've been
better and I wish it was better.
It may be a little bit, but I'm not going
to have ever beat myself up over it.
Well, it's just one of those
things where you, when you,
when you look back and you think of all
the great things that you did accomplish,
then you realize that
you're retired at 30. Yeah.
So much so much room there,
you know, thirties so young.
You're in your athletic prime.
They, I think they say 32
for professional fighter.
They consider most athletic primes at 32
there was, but you know, uh, I look back
on it and again, you know, the 42 fights,
that's a lot of fights. Um, plus I
started when I was nine and a half,
a little over a hundred amateur fights
during, there was a lot. What that,
I mean for a while there'd
be a while before I retired,
I was throwing it around,
you know, retiring. I was one of them
guys that just, I liked it and I loved it,
but I also sometimes got tired of it.
You know,
I'm a very simple guy
and, and uh, it don't,
I don't care about the Glam
or to fame or any of that.
I truly don't, you know,
like even now what my,
my podcast and what I'm doing with some
of these other adventures because I got
bored and I'm on to have fun. Right. You
know what I mean? And keep myself busy.
And,
um,
I've been fortunate to have what I have
to be able to do all this on my own,
you know, and go out there and
be around everybody. But yeah.
So when I was fighting,
you know,
there was a lot of rumors around
up to retirement, this, that,
and I think the final icing on a cake
was we were supposed to fight Andre Ward
and that's when Andre Ward ended up
getting a shoulder surgery and I fight,
fell through.
And I've been out in California training
or an Ochsner trainer for almost a year,
which most fighters leave at the
beginning of their career. You know,
when they don't have a family,
when they're not making the money,
that's our opportunity to
try and go and make money,
not when you're 12 years
into it, you know. And uh,
so I went out there and that kind of
took a little bit from here as far as the
sport, even though I loved it and it was
great training with, uh, Robert Garcia.
I learned so much that I think I could
learn at that state point in my career.
And not that Andre Ward fight fell
through. Um, I was, I was done. I mean,
I was, I rolled over, I never forget,
I rolled over, told my wife, I said,
I think I'm done. And she goes, what
are you talking about? And as an,
I think I'm retiring.
And she started crying tears
of joy because she wanted
me to be done even before
that. She don't know to sport or
but what prime ages or not. And, uh,
I hung them up and, and you know,
over the years as we talked earlier,
Herron who I would get the Itch,
you know,
and that could have been just going to
the gym and Aetna are doing around on the
pads, but I just didn't ever want it
to keep doing it. You know, my health,
believe it or not is more
important than anything else.
Well that is something that
every fighter has to consider.
Like when have they fought too much?
Yeah.
How do you make that
decision when your heart,
when you lose it in here
and that hard a little bit.
It's a horrible hobby to have, especially
at that high of a level. You know,
cause you're not fighting guys that are
getting off work at three o'clock and
you know,
you're fighting guys that are legit
athletes and skilled professionals that
fighting and um, it's dangerous.
Unfortunately, we've seen,
and no one we're talking about this,
uh, with me getting the itch earlier,
there's a lot of things I take
in consideration. Like, I'm,
I'm really intuit and I'm really debating
on it and I'm hitting the gym work in
boxing. Did I see things like this? A
Donna Stevenson situation, you know,
and those are the
things where I say,
I got to sit back and talk to explain
to people what happened. He just,
he got hit and it was a good fight.
He's been fighting for years now.
One of the most feared
fighters also in boxing.
He fought the guy we were
talking about earlier. Yeah. Uh,
I can't pronounce his name.
Um, I don't want to chop it up.
Pull up the Russian gentleman's name.
We, yeah, there's a way to say it.
It's a, uh, better be, but
I see them all at Donna Stevenson.
Okay.
It's rushing cats. I have some crazy ass
news, man. They do. I know. It's hard.
You know,
me being a guy involved in a sport and
talking about it all the time to how hard
it is for me. Yeah. To get
it down. There's so many
bad ass Russians these days.
Okay. It's who Bostic. Yeah, it's GV. Oh,
z. D y. K. But it's vas. Dick,
you don't pronounce the G Wozniak.
He sent me these two men.
He's a beast. So in that fight again,
Donna Stevenson is a brutal puncher,
devastating knockout puncher.
He's been fighting all
these years now also.
And this is the part that's the
scary one on one, right? 41. Yes.
And that's another situation or you know,
factor factor where you might want to
say, Hey, I'm done. Right. You know,
even before this happened, unfortunately
had to get to this point. But uh,
he's in there and it's a fairly
decent fight from what I was watching.
And next thing you know,
he goes down at fights over and he
dropped Fonzie kids at some point in the
fight. He did. Yeah. And He,
uh, next thing you know, he
ends up in a coma, you know,
fighting for his life to the sport.
You never know.
That's the scary thing about it.
You know,
you could get injured two weeks
before the flight, the sparring,
and have a little bleed that you
would ever, no, no, no signs of it.
And then the next thing you're,
you're in a coma. Yeah. Well,
I know that that really fucked up
Roy Jones Jr when Gerald Mcclellan,
who was his arch rival,
you know,
this was the guy that they thought one
day he was going to fight when McAllen
was killing it at light heavyweight
and Roy was 168 pound champion.
And then you know,
to see mccloughan now you know,
people who don't remember man
McClellan was a fucking destroyer.
He was so God damn scary and so good
and he hits so hard and he was the guy
that, you know, Amusa
Cronk fighter, you know,
in the vein of Tommy Hearns and all those
other great Cronk fighters and people
looked at him like, man, one day
that's going to be the fight.
Him and Roy Jones Jr was almost
like it was inevitable. Yeah.
It was like Canelo and triple
j or something. I know,
cause everybody does the fantasy matchups
and they asked me if I Pavlik Verse
Michaela and I'm going,
what are you guys trying to do to me?
I don't want it that fight. You know
what I mean? Cause he did it that hard.
He was a brutal guy.
Yeah.
And then to see him when he
fought Nigel Benn, same situation,
lapse into that coma.
We don't know how a dynasty Woodson
is going to come out of this, but um,
a lot of times when a guy does
have a brain injury like that,
like they're never the same again.
Yup. That's what I was saying.
I like it could have happened that could
have been something two weeks earlier
that was never detected or signs
of it. So it's scary. It is.
Um, so you take that into consideration,
but you also have that itch. Yeah.
You know, and again, I, I'm 36, um,
is is something that again,
it's going to be a process of sitting
down and discussing, you know,
what he's going to,
would you say you like 60% considering
finding again maybe a little more right
now? No, no, no. Ooh, I know.
Um, do you ever like go back and watch
like highlight reels and then you start
shadowbox and again,
itchy and really start thinking around it.
And it's weird because I'm in my gym and,
and there was people lifting
weights and I'm in the back.
I got a couple of bags
back there. And, um,
you start hearing the bags
popping in and everybody,
they're not used to seeing it,
so everybody gets curious and they
come back and you see them like peeking
around the corner and watching me
hit the bag and then I get a little
embarrassed. I'm like, all right.
You know what? I'm just gonna,
I'm gonna Chill with it right now.
So, yeah, it's a, it's fun. It is.
It's a thought again and
we'll, we'll see. But the,
a lot of that plays in my mind because
the one thing is it becomes very selfish
to, at a point, I got two
young kids at home, you know,
that's going to be 13 and 10.
They're involved in sports
and a lot of activities.
They love me being around for it.
And it don't take me half an a fighter.
You sick, right. For something to
happen. You know what I mean? Um,
but we'll, we'll toss it around and
we'll, we'll see how that goes. Yeah,
that's, um, that's a big consideration.
There's a lot of things to
factor in on that. Well,
especially because you are busy now. And
so what made you decide to do a podcast?
Actually, I was excited when I heard
you were doing that and I was like,
all right. Yeah, you get into the podcast
where I am, I'm looking at, you know,
I hear some of these guys,
uh, commentating and I say,
I think I could do that.
Yeah,
you could do that.
After listening and the podcast we're
kind of throwing around. Um, I had,
like I said,
I got a handful of investments going on
and I pick and choose on what I want to
do and the podcast started
off, uh, hey, let's have fun.
Let's throw this podcast on.
We'll get some cheap equipment.
We know got a lot of
followers on social media,
so we'll do like the social media live
and then we'll also hook it to the
youtube and we're doing it. And it
started off for a little wilder. Um,
but no advertisement,
it was kind of lonely.
You know,
you're going,
if you feel like I'm talking into a mic
and nobody's there and then it started
taking it, it's doing fairly well right
now. It's how many downloads again, man,
I'm right now the social media is
the biggest. We ended up pitting.
It reaches out after the first episode,
you got 2000 people were reached and
maybe like 400 views and then as the days
go on and to share his go on,
you started seeing it reaches out to
over like 27,000 people and then you see,
you know, uh, 8,000 views.
So in, so on social media,
Youtube is the one I'm working for,
you know, really trying to push.
And right now sometimes we get up 113
views on there and then sometimes I don't
even want to mention how many
dudes are on it. Uh, so again,
it's a process with that. Also, I know
that I'm starting to learn that. Um,
it's about consistency. That's the
most important thing. But I get,
I get out to these fights and
people will know, you know who,
who don't comment on a show
because we do it words.
It's live to format of it is to have
everybody involved cause they liked that.
They get ask questions and we're pretty
much faces on the phone and reading the
questions and answering it.
And I think they liked that.
And actually it's kind of funny because
we'll get some great guests on there.
We had Tj Dillashaw,
we had Mikey Garcia,
Terrence Crawford on how did you get out?
I think you could bring back Joe Lewis
and put them on there and people don't
care about that. They want their
questions answered, you know,
through social media or through youtube
and they kind of don't interact with the
guests that you have one. So it's,
it's weird. Um, I think the format,
I liked the format of it,
but at the same time I wish people would
be more involved with the guests that
we have one. But for the most
part it's fun. It's different.
But that kind of format.
It's well boxing fans in particular,
well I should say just combat
sports fans in particular.
They'd love to comment on things.
We'll have to get in on it. I mean,
whenever there's a big fight,
I mean social media just lights
up both with boxing and with MMA.
They live in La and the ability to go
back and forth with the guy like you and
get your questions answered and stuff
like that. It's gotta be huge. Yup.
And we tap in. We've had Matt
Brown on so we tap into the UFC.
I personally don't want to,
cause I don't want to make nobody mad.
I don't know enough.
I watch it and I couldn't get anybody mad.
But I'm saying that some of the fans,
you know, I would watch it, I enjoy it.
But my now the Cohoes James Domingez,
he's really big into that, you know?
And he was the one that
actually introduced me to
Matt Brown and so he knows so
on now show, that's where we
work hand in hand together.
Like he's able to do
more of the questions.
And I think it's fun when
boxers don't know about him.
A man they ass wonky questions. I
know. That's how I felt with, you know,
vice versa. So I'm sure man.
Yeah, I'm sure like when you,
when a big fight goes
down and um, you uh, do,
do you watch it and stream
live? We do a, well we tried,
we actually tried on that.
That's a great idea for someone like
you that we do a thing called the fight
companion. We do it all the
time with, as a UFC fight,
we'll put it up on that screen.
We'll have a bunch of guys in here and
we'll watch the fights and talk shit
while the fights are going on and
people play it alongside the commentary.
So it's like they're watching the fights
with us. Yeah, that's an idea. Thank you.
That's great idea. Yeah, absolutely
is. And that's the whole thing.
We're just looking for different.
Plus if you,
if you go into the comments and start, you
know, having people ask questions like,
what do you think won that round?
Then you go, this is why, you know,
I think triple g one the round,
this is why Canelo lost the round.
Or this is why you could make an
argument that canela wanted that,
that kind of stuff for that kind of
interaction stuff for the fans. Love that.
They love it. They love that. And
that's it. That's what we're, you know,
we're looking at different ideas to you
cause you've never stopped learning.
You can never stop, you know, expanding
and doing things like that. So it's good.
And you know, we get places, we get
to these big fights and, and uh,
people notice the show, you know, hey,
I love your show. Even if they don't,
you're saying that to
me, you know? Um, yeah,
it was a very keen insight. Right. Yeah.
You know, and it was cool actually. What
was that, the first triple g Canelo fight?
You know, when I retired, I stayed
away from boxing. I went to that, uh,
I went there and I was all about promoting
my podcast and, uh, it was kinda cool.
I walked in there and everybody went crazy
in the media room and I thought I was
fighting again after we,
after five years of being retired,
I thought I was fighting.
I mean they were just asking and I was
trying to squeeze stuff in and tell him
what I was doing. And then it was cool
also because Bernard Hopkins was there,
you know, and I was just, I was
already a year into the power lifting.
I was still about two 30.
And he came up and a,
you gave me a big hug and you know,
it was awesome to be able to after a
fight and being able to go in there with
him to see how nice he wasn't
and how humble he was after that,
you know,
you could have been cocky.
He could've walked past me and I
said hi or recognize me at all.
He was just really, uh, brought
me in. So that's cool. Yeah.
What did he say to you after the fight?
Did he tell you need to box like a
black guy? I think he did. You know,
after that fight,
he could of told me everything he wanted
and Rodica sat down for an hour with me
and I wouldn't remember what
he said. Um, I was, you know,
everybody's seen the
fight, so I don't, I mean,
I need not to say much
more on that, but, uh, he,
a little bit of it because my trainer was
there. It was, you'll keep your head up,
you're a hell of a fighter,
you know, and, and, you know,
I'm experienced and go back,
go back to the drawing board.
Don't get too down on this and come
back strong. He goes, you're a champ.
And then that was what he's remember
something where he said that you needed to
learn how to fuck the black guy. I didn't
hear that. I truly didn't, you know,
and maybe he might've said that in an
interview after with somebody and that's
what people thought, but I know he didn't
say it in a fight. Yeah. Yeah. That was,
um, that was, uh, was, you know, one
of his best performances. I mean,
he had so many great
performances late in his career.
The Tito Trinidad find in
particular because nobody,
nobody thought he was going
to win that fight. That was,
he was a big underdog in that fight.
Trinidad was the up and coming rising
Puerto Rican superstar was fucking
everybody up and Bernard put
on a show. I thought, you know,
I actually had a Hopkins, the knife
fight toe because he was just bigger,
you know, the big guy, middle
weight Trinidad's moving up. And uh,
there was a lot of good middle waste
side and think Trinidad was going to be,
I think Trinidad was a amazing
fighter by the kids. Great days.
We're at one 47. Yeah.
Grill. Yeah, I was, um,
I mean he was a big puncher though.
I mean he was a big puncher,
even up into light heavyweight.
I mean you'd been into a little
weight middleweight but he was,
his style was almost tailor made
for Bernard or no, I was so,
so clever. It's such a good counter
fighters. So good defensively.
He didn't really open up,
he didn't leave many openings.
That goes back to the foot work
that we were talking about.
He noticed when he flat that fight,
even when he fought me,
but Trinidad and other guys,
when they go to throw a punch,
he take that one step in and
kind of suffer Kate to punch.
And especially if it was a straight
right hand or did he would take that step
and he would overthrow that overhand
right and catch you what it,
so he was really good at just
putting a foot, not moving around,
much putting in the right spot to hit
you and counter you. Um, and he did that.
Trinidad was probably one of the
best technically sound fighters ever.
If you actually watch them, you
know, the way to his punches.
He'd never made mistakes
on that part of it,
but I think he needed a little bit more
change it up a little different with
Bernard Hopkins in order to have
even made that fight kind of clothes.
One of the most ridiculous
turning that fights ever.
Remember we fought Ricardo Mayorga and my
org and let them punch him in the face.
Yeah. He just put his hands down and go,
go ahead and intense Trinidad teed off.
I think he hit him with two left
hooks on the chin. My role was crazy.
He was so crazy.
That was a crazy dude.
Smoke cigarettes in
between rounds and shit.
I don't even know if I could believe that.
I don't know if that was a show and he
did that when the cameras are on because
he was able to go a handful of
rounds without getting tired.
Now I know if you smoke a cigarette man,
that's going to take the wind
out of you. Yeah, but you know,
I know fighters that smoke.
Yeah. Yeah. Joe Schilling,
who's a worldclass kickboxer a top of
the food chain world champion kickboxer
smoke cigarettes. Well, crazy fucker
man. I chewed most of my career.
It's different though,
right? It is. You know,
chew nicotine restricts the oxygen in
the blood and it's not good for a boxers
or or anybody lifting weights.
Nicotine does.
Chewing Tobacco restore restricts the
oxygen in the blood. I didn't know that,
but can you pull it up? Just make sure
just a stimulant though. You know,
it's actually like for your brain.
People say the a lot of
folks I actually bought some,
I never tried it but I
bought some nicotine gum to
try to see if I would write
on it.
Like if it would help me writing.
Like cause it apparently it works as
a nootropic as a cognitive enhancer.
Nicotine is actually an effective
cognitive enhancer. I didn't know that.
Maybe how much you take of
it. The quantity. Yeah. I
don't know. I mean I don't,
I didn't know that it uh, it affects
your, cause it's a stimulant.
I didn't know that. It restricts
the oxygen, your blood.
That's pretty good from what I,
from what I heard and chew actually more
so than cigarettes because of the, uh,
amount of nicotine on how it hits.
It gets into the stream faster.
But to me it was never,
I didn't chew a day of the fight
and I believe after so many hours,
six to eight or 10 hours, um,
it's out. So, but any of the,
or it didn't affect me that stuff.
So now cause I was able to run
three miles and 19 minutes,
19 some minutes and five miles
and 30 minutes. And, and uh,
I was in, I was chewing it so
it never really affected me.
Um, well maybe it did, but just you
were in such good shape, shape, barely,
no smoking on the other hand,
lungs filling them. It is horrible.
And uh, but after I retired and the
itch wasn't there for like a year,
I, I, I wanted to give the gums a break
and I decided, well you know what else?
Smoke and I quit smoking shortly.
Started smoking cigarettes after
you retire that Jesus Christ,
I didn't want to start. Someone else
starts at 30. I was switching out cause I,
it was nicotine here. Oh
here it is. Smoke tobacco,
smokeless tobacco and health
risks. Uh, but, but, but, but, but,
but both the amount of nicotine in the
bloodstream after using smokeless tobacco
may be higher than that of
a cigarette smoker. Okay.
What does it say about oxygen now?
That's where it was going into debt.
This puts it all together. The nicotine
based is taking the place of the oxygen,
I think is what the other, there's
another, it's a less scientific paper,
but nicotine stays in the blood stream
longer with smokeless tobacco than
cigarettes.
Oral Tobacco causes heart disease.
Okay. It's not a safe alternative folks.
That's what it's saying. All right.
We're [inaudible] bad for you. But
you started smoking cigarettes. Yeah.
Cause not because when you were smoking,
when you drinking kind of guys that what
it was? No, it was because I wanted,
I liked the nicotine. Oh. And
I chewed, you know, and uh,
I wanted to give the gums or break
the lips of break and I smoked.
So I waited and have to chew and uh,
doing the lifting and power lifting.
I went over and I think I've got seven
squats and I couldn't breathe Jesus.
And I said, you know what? This is a
shame. How long have you been smoking for?
I was only eight months.
Several months. That's long
enough on it, you know. And uh,
yeah, I said, you know what,
cause I had no plans coming
back to the ring. I didn't.
So I was done and uh,
yeah, I got to seven,
seven reps into the squat and I
was like, you know, this is a sad,
that was a former, you know,
world class athlete. So I,
I was done right after that day, but to
cigarettes back. I'm a good for you. Yeah,
I'm sad you started it up, but glad
you figured out to let it go. Yes.
You that's a,
that's a weird choice though at 30.
Yeah.
I'm just cause smoking bull is nicotine,
you know,
and that's what a lot of people do. When
I tried to quit, uh, the children, they,
they, they go over to the smoke
and then just go to the gum.
Usually you could do that too, but some
people would just like it. Um, yeah.
I don't know what it does. It does juicy
up. Tony Hinchcliffe a smoked cigarettes.
He doesn't anymore,
but he used to and a couple of times I
took a cigarette from him and smoked it
before I went onstage and he's like,
dude, you're going to get hurt.
He was worried about me. You're going to
get hurt. I'm not going to get hooked.
Yeah. I'm just going to smoke this one
cigarette. I'm not going to go buy a pack.
But people are so scared of it. Yeah.
Well I see why though. Yeah. You know,
especially again, you know,
as I'm mentioning, I'm over.
I used to be able to do all that
and then I do seven reps on a
squat night and I'm having a hard
time breathing and, uh, I racked it.
Now granted we're, squats are hard
though. I mean, you're going to,
if you're spending on a weight
and how many reps you're doing,
it's a different type of exercise. But
you know, I, I was done after that.
So you had a drinking thing
for a while too, Huh? Yeah.
That's, that's one that, uh, that
gets a lot of fighters. Yeah,
it does. Um, but it's one
that, you know, on that,
that it ticks me off and it
don't, it ticks you off. Yeah.
How so you'd, a lot of it was
ran through to the hometown,
you know, and the troubles
that I, that I got in with the,
um, TMZ, stuff like that, you know,
the incidents that
happened were petty small.
And if it was,
it wasn't in Youngstown,
it would've never made news
stuff that kind of happens. Shit.
Bb guns and in a four wheeler. Yeah,
I shot a kid. We were playing around.
I was taking care of them.
And this is the truth of the story
taking care of them. I was putting a,
a big lake in my backyard and uh,
I got the country boy. I mean,
I went out and rented two excavators and
some bobcats and started putting, uh,
the ponded this,
uh,
this guy I was helping out. He knows
how to run the excavators. So I,
he needed work.
He had no money.
I was taking care of him and his kids
over at the house. He's, he's working.
So long story short,
after about five days,
I'll come home and he's in the pond
or lake just in his underwear playing
around. I grabbed the BB gun. I'm
joking around with him, you know,
cause we were shooting targets for a
couple of days in between work and I shoot
him in the,
uh,
on the arm for 42 years old at
the 41 years old at the time too.
So it wasn't a kid. He gets out, he's
like, yeah, you shot me. And, and uh,
he's crying about it and everything
else. And next thing you know, he,
he's cool though. He gets out of these,
it's on Facebook and he's Giggling,
laughing about it and he stays at my
house that night. His kids come over,
I'm feeding them, we're having
cookouts the next day, a little things.
I don't know that I'm glad that I'm
not involved in no more or I don't put
myself in a situation.
So He's,
he stays for two days after
that at my house. And uh,
his uncle comes there who worked for the
sheriff, the local sheriff's department,
and it goes, hey, is so and so
here? And I said, yeah, he was,
I haven't seen him. No. And he
goes, okay, listen. He goes, Kelly,
I'm coming here to tell you.
So I way the news, the media,
everything else don't come.
He has a warrant out for his
arrest and tell him, you know,
if he comes back, call us. So he leaves,
I go walk it through
the house and they come.
Brian comes down the steps and I was like,
dude,
you gotta get the Hell Outta here. I was
like, I didn't know anything about this.
You having a warrant, blah blah, blah.
He goes over and pass out on my couch.
I call his uncle, hey, you want
him? He's here. So he finds out,
he ends up running out of the
house and they catch him, you know,
that night or whatever,
they take him in,
he does two months and a county jail,
gets out,
takes his uniform off,
walks over to the sheriff's department.
Sheriff's department and
presses. Charges on you. Yes.
For shooting him with a BB gun.
Yes.
And a buddy of mine who was there
when it happened was video in it.
His girlfriends laughing in the
background, you know when it happened.
But that was,
it was just a video of it happening.
He'd sold it to a TMZ
and next thing you know,
I ended up getting served or what not.
My attorney calls me also
and it says, Hey, go down,
turn yourself in. You know,
it's a federal assault charge.
Yeah. Kinds of federal
assault. Yes. Yeah. And uh,
that was it. And again, it was all
over money. It was a drawn out case.
I'm supposed to have been beat and it
turned to that over a BB gun but a guy and
he said it was an assault.
So I always trying to get from you.
You got nine grand and it was supposed to,
when he filed a civil suit
or a couple months into this,
the criminal charges are supposed to be
dropped at that point because prosecutor
and everybody knew that
it was all about money.
So today we're going to drop the
criminal charge. They never did.
And uh, it goes back in
Youngstown, you know,
I was out in the public eye and someone
that people would eight, they had it out.
They have
to for people to understand how big
star you are in Youngstown. I mean,
I remember at the time,
I remember reading stories,
seeing news clips mean Youngstown's not
a big place and other than ray boom,
boom, man seen. He's not a whole
lot of like really famous people,
especially fighters had
come at a young sound,
but you were a fucking
giant celebrity in that.
Yeah. And that was Kinda my, my bad
on that. That's where I think the,
the fault was probably hard for you to
recognize. You're not even 30 years old.
Yeah. All this shit is going
on. Yeah. And it's true.
And I'm not looking for that as an excuse.
You know when I say it, but it is true.
I looked, I looked at myself as everybody
else. Right. I think that was the issue
you hadn't recognized yet that
you're in some weird place.
We have to watch what you,
I felt like if I go to
the bar and somebody goes,
boy you Kelly public's been
here three days. He's a lush.
My argument was I got every right to be
here just like you do. Matter of fact,
I have more of a right. You know, I'm
retired. I've got my money put away,
you're probably drinking your
weekly pay away. That was my,
my thought processes,
thought process of that and it was
probably wasn't right. You know,
because it comes down to is you are a big
fish in a little pond and it's a small
city and I think that by being out there,
I brought a lot on myself because of that.
It is what it is.
Unfortunately as an athlete
you, you can't do that. And um,
so that happened over a period of time
and the word got around and a lot of
anger, you know, you have
some jealous, some angry,
there's some who just didn't like me.
So just so much fun for them to gossip.
Yeah, exactly. Cause what else is really
not beating up young song. I love it.
It made me who I am.
But if you really look up young Saunders
not drained a lot to talk about besides
the fact that we do put out the
most NFL players per capita. Really?
Oh absolutely. Youngstown does. Why
is that you think? I don't know.
Is Averages there? Just some, some bad ass
dudes from, from Youngstown. And it is,
I don't, I don't know why, I
mean, even the boxing part of it,
if you truly break down the five rural
champs from such a small city and 36
years as, as it came up with the other
world champs besides the [inaudible] area,
royal actually held the title
in the same way class Ron,
the same exact time that Massey and
he did, he had Jeff Lampkin, uh,
Greg Richardson.
And uh,
then you had a handful of other guys like
Roland Cummings and fighters out there
that were making noise out of Youngstown.
A guy can say granny who fought
Chavez and Comacho out of Youngstown.
But,
um,
being at being at being there like that,
it brought a lot of attention and
people wanted, wanted, you know,
and there was a lot of angry people.
Was it weird growing up there and then
becoming a famous guy there? Yeah, it is.
Because again, you know, you
don't, people will tell you, hey,
when you get to that level,
when you wouldn't have rolled title,
Shit's going to change man. And you're
going, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. You think,
you know, right. Like you're going,
yeah, I got what you're saying.
And then it happens and you win it.
And it's so true when they say overnight,
like you're not, you know
more, you know, like you're,
you can't be yourself no more.
It's a everything changes and
it comes down to the person.
Even though if you don't want to change
and you like living your life the way
you did two days ago, uh, fortunately
you can't, you know, and it's,
it's a hard, and it's something that
you got to learn how to deal with.
And that, that wasn't my choice
though. You know what I mean by that?
My choice wasn't to go out
and act like a jack alone.
My choice was kind of just be me though.
And um,
you just did what you wanted to do.
I did.
And then it just became a big issue
because you were a famous guy.
Yes.
And the,
another issue on top of that came to was
where I could actually take the blame
for this. And, and I honestly
cam a lot of it came down to,
and everybody's different. So
I'm not, I'm speaking for myself.
I trained my ass off when I
trained, you know, I was a six,
seven hours a day type guy and uh,
that's what got me to throw as many
punches as I did around, you know,
and I was in great shape
for every fight. I sacrifice a lot
of things. I gave up a lot, you know,
I'm even starting from high school,
you know,
being an amateurs and just turning
pro right out of high school.
I missed a lot of things. My mentality
was when, you know, I had time,
I was going to,
I was going to live,
I was going to live like my
friends who were 19, 20, 21,
24 and that was the process of it.
Um,
I do believe though, at a point,
especially after I retired,
that it got a little, got a little
out of hand. Absolutely. You know,
and I'm not going to be the person
to sit her and say, you know, it did,
I'm not naive enough to say that.
Well, you know better than anybody,
but the rumors were always that
you were drinking a lot, but,
and that was affecting your career.
It may have to at some point.
I don't think it did.
People say,
use the fact that Hopkins beat me and
that was this. That was the reason.
And that's why I retired so young
and it wasn't, it truly wasn't. Um,
maybe some of the stuff I was doing,
especially as I got older in
between flights to drinking,
I think that that could have,
that may have heard a little bit.
I don't think it was enough to make
any significant changes in my career,
to be honest with you. Um, but
you know, who knows what that,
if I didn't, we'll never know. Um, again,
but I lived up and do I got
anything to regret about it? No.
Do you still live in Youngstown? Yeah,
we're on the outside in the suburbs.
You know, is it, I mean,
it's gotta be strange to have
grown up there, been a child there,
and then become an internationally famous
world champion boxer and celebrity and
still stay there.
Yeah.
It's the world changes and you're
still Kelly Pavlick and I think after I
retired,
as far as some of the mistakes I've
come to where I should have gotten out,
maybe come out here to
California or go to a on. Yeah,
right. I don't, yeah, we're working
on it. Plenty of room. Yeah.
Just had that last night. What my, uh,
manager, uh, mark he was telling me,
talking about you doing out here.
Can you say he's throwing
around ideas also again,
we were talking about what
we have talked about earlier,
but to fight coming back, uh, we talked
about the dancing with the stars. Things.
Is that some ideas he's looking into?
Also sponsorships, um, you know,
again, mark is, um, got a lot of
connects. He's in that industry.
Boxing's in an interesting
place right now and I'm really,
I was really bummed out that uh, HBO
canceled their boxing series. I mean,
after how many years? It's 40, 43
years. Something crazy like that.
They put on some of the all time.
Great classic fights. And, you know,
I think Jim Lampley,
one of the best commentators of all time,
I loved hearing Roy Jones Jr
do it and Andre Ward and she,
you know, I just, Max
Kellerman was amazing. I just,
I just can't believe that it's
over. I mean, not, I don't know,
I guess it wasn't profitable for them
or they just decided to get out of the,
I really don't understand it.
I don't believe that it's going to
be gone for long from Hbo. I, yeah,
I have for some reason, I
think you noticed, uh, Lampley
still has the fight game.
That was an error in her donut.
Um,
I heard rumors of maybe
Roy Jones taking it over,
buying it out or somebody buying. Yeah.
Um, but a big issue I think where that,
what happens in to HBO and showtime
is doing very well right now. Yeah.
And I don't know yet.
I'm not sure if we'll ever fall
into this situation that HBO did,
but you have these apps coming out now.
Espn plus a disowned DAZN.
And again, like what they just had that
signing what Canelo how big that was.
The richest athlete, you
know, the biggest contracts,
$150 million or something for,
I thought it was three 65 and some
Canelo's how much money if something,
I think it was 365 million, but
he, there was also per, you know,
incentives and everything else but that,
so 365 and it was a six in there.
That's a lot of fucking money. Yes it
is for I think 11 fights or whatever.
It was crazy. And um, so again,
that's where these people were
coming to this ESPN plus tig.
They could wash these fights. Now on
these four, seven, nine, nine, nine,
nine 99 a disown has UFC or MMA fight bar,
I think it's spelled tour fights,
whatever.
It is nice that ESPN is putting
on a lot of fights now. Exactly.
They also now have a deal
with the UFC. So, uh,
into 2019 now the first UFC event,
it's going to be January 19th,
which is Tj Dillashaw versus Henry
Cejudo for the flyweight title.
And they're really putting
on some great fights on ESPN.
It's just exciting just to see
MMA being recognized, be ESPN.
But it's exciting to see ESPN put
like Llama Chanko fights on. Exactly.
Cause Espn used to be kind of more so
the prospects you can go to Friday night
fights where are the up and
coming guys and they were,
they were putting out on and
that was great for the prospects.
I think they need to actually keep
doing that maybe on a different night.
But now they're putting the loan with
Cenk goes and we're putting in a rural
class fighters on ESPN Crawford's last
fight on ESPN I believe it was. You know,
that's awesome. That's awesome. Yeah.
So that and that APP that
ESPN plus like I'm saying,
so there's more accessibility to that
and people would rather pay that then
order to 69 or 89 or $100
paper review funds. Right.
Seven bucks a month is nice.
It is. I mean with the UFC,
the UFC has a UFC fight pass and you know
they have events just constantly same
sort of deal and that's great for that.
It is because it's easier route, you know,
outlet for it. Yeah. And you can watch
on your phone on, on a train. Exactly.
It's like the,
the world's changing and now also,
I love the fact you could stream
it from your phone, right.
To your television and you got a smart
TV. You can watch it. Exactly. Yeah.
You know, I was even thinking about
that at my gym because I know how it is.
What business in ordering
paper view fights.
There was actually a funny story about
that and Youngstown with that too. Um,
where everybody thought it
was my fault. But uh, yeah,
you could get that and I got to have
40 people there on a big fight night,
UFC fight night or a boxing fight night
and I could just put that phone right up
to the smart TV. We could watch it on
there instead of paying, don't say this,
don't say this right now. They're
going to come get you. Oh yeah.
You're not going to do that. This is all
hypothetical. This will never happen.
You're not going to do that.
Right. Thought it was leaving.
No, I'd be legal. Yeah.
Well the UFC is gone after people in the
past for illegally streaming things and
then showing them on television. Oh,
well I thought if you had the APP,
I don't know. I don't know how to be
honest when you're showing it on a,
in a business, because I know
what I was talking about earlier,
what the young style thing that happened,
it was kind of funny was um,
they were getting the fights,
the paper view of fights and they were,
some of the businesses were illegally
getting it and AOL got fine.
They were going around and people
were actually coming to me like,
I have something to do with it. They
were like, I can't believe you'd do that.
You should have to pay us like
$3,000 for to find out what you got.
And I'm going, yes. I
started googling, I'm going,
last time my mind was,
I was worried about was who was ordering
fights in Youngstown. What I'm hearing,
you know, Atlantic City or
Vegas right now fighting, um,
getting ready to try to make weight
and doing the interviews and the press
conference.
And everything else.
What kind of asshole says that you should
have hit? It kind of came out in one.
Actually, my brother was doing, uh,
going to get ads for the program from
places and they're like, I'm not giving,
I'm not putting an ad and he costs
me $3,000. You know, you cost you,
you fucking pirate.
I,
he might nighties and I'm sure I'm not
just using that with the young side.
That would probably would have happened
anywhere, you know, small, small area.
So while, you know, illegal streaming, if
they don't do something about it, man, uh,
it would run rampant. I just don't know
what the thing to do. That's correct is,
you know, I've seen some outrageous
fines. I don't know. You know,
and as you, as we just have about what
happened earlier, we don't know what's,
what's legal and what's not either or
anymore with all the different, uh,
Internet stuff and apps that you have.
And it was a smart TVs with TVs. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, or, you know,
can you stream it on your phone and
have a bunch of people look over your
shoulder? Yeah. How's that work for you?
If you have a smart TV though, you know,
like if you have it on your phone and
then like 20 of your friends come over and
they're behind you. Yeah. And you say,
hey man, everybody give me a dollar.
He get in trouble for that and I was
at work or that could be a great idea.
It's not the worst idea. But yeah. The,
how does that work? Because with Apple TV,
anything you're watching,
you can watch a youtube video and you just
stream it to that TV with a, you know,
a quick swipe and oppress Bam. Yeah. Yeah.
I think the move for them is
to make it easily accessible.
Like a WWE was the first one to
figure that out. Right. They,
they figured out how to,
you get like a monthly subscription and
you get to watch all the events and then
the UFC did that with fight pass
and ESPN plus doing this and you,
he knows how to make the money. Yeah.
We could all see. Sure. Um, you know,
I think it was also great as somebody
who's insights station, you know,
local stations and inside putting these
fights on also like they used to do back
in the day, you know what, ABC fights
and uh, oh it was a CBS sports. Yeah,
yeah. All that shit do not again,
you know, why, why wouldn't us?
It's great for the sport and you know,
that's how you get people
involved back in it. You know,
it's almost like almost every
other generation or, or, or,
or every other decade there was that
group of fighters that come out, you know,
he like the Frazier guys like that.
Then you had like the Tyson
holy filled Reddick bow,
but you also, at that time it was
easy and it was accessible to,
to watch all the time. Now, you
know, it's not even the apps,
which is I think is great.
You get a lot of guys in their forties
and fifties who don't want to have to
watch an APP on your TV. So I think
if they start bringing it back up,
just a little more variety of,
uh, shows or something. Well,
it seems like,
especially with boxing right now,
the talent level is extremely high. I
mean it is with them, I may as well.
But I mean with boxing it
seems to be on an upswing.
And it also seems like people really
interested in some of these big rivalries
like triple g and Canelo.
That was two amazing fights.
I thought the first one was a robbery.
I thought that a triple g one the first
one, but they don't fight again. Really?
Yeah. Why is that? Because, uh,
when you get a guy that hits as hard as
triple g does and you get a guy that's
as good as Canelo, you know,
and, and they're, and there,
even though they're not getting dropped
and are not getting knocked out,
the dumb type of flights take a
lot out of you. They really do.
And they shared a lot in those
two fights and we don't know,
even right now if the next fight or to
fight after that Canelo start showing
somebody effects from those first
two fights. You think so? Yeah.
You get a guy that hits two guys that hit
that hard and earned her fighting like
that, eventually it does drain you
a little bit and that will catch up.
I think a third fight we'll
shorten the career of Canelo.
I'm not going to say triple g
because triple g is my age now and I,
I have a feeling that his might be
getting short here pretty soon anyways,
just due to age. But Canelo I mean
that, that's, it was a brutal fights.
They were brutal fights.
Did you think that um,
some people thought that triple g one,
the second fight as well.
I thought it was much closer.
Fine done the first fight.
But did you think that Canelo triple g,
I think Conello showed some improvement,
but it's also possible that triple
g might've slowed down a little bit.
I think so. Um, you know,
the first fight I had at nine 30 for
triple g that's how I spent sounds about
right.
Yeah.
And I gave the first three
rounds to Canelo and then
I had every round after for
triple g this fight,
I thought Canelo one close fight.
And if you gave it to triple g,
I wouldn't have screened where are bright.
You know, teddy was saying that he thought
the triple g one, but, um, I felt like,
well it's a pretty close
fight pretty close by,
but certainly Conello
showed much improvement.
He did and he fought a better fight.
The first half of the fight
I gave a keynote a lot of
eyebrows because I thought
he controlled the fight
with the two body shots.
Everybody thought triple g was
controlling it with the jab,
but the reason why it triple g wasn't
using his size and strength was because it
was using his jab was cause of the body
shots that Canelo was landing. I mean,
they were brutal. And, uh,
I just thought Canelo dictated the
pace of those first couple of rounds.
I thought he won enough of the early
rounds and obviously triple g one the
second most of the
second half of the fight,
but I thought it was a little too late,
you know,
and I had Canelo up by around
her too. Yeah. Um, it's,
it's just one,
those are,
those are two fighters that
really sort of epitomize, uh,
what people like to see when they like
to see like these classic rivalries,
right? Like a guy like triple
g who's just forward pressure,
constant throwing bombs,
knockout puncher or garlic Canelo
who's just one of those classic Mexican
fighters that as incredible heart
wants to fight the best of the best,
like really like really takes
it in the first fight. Yeah.
Yeah. It's the on the ropes
with triple g and let him,
let him use that power to beat your
organs. Then Pardot sites, you know,
I was sitting, I'm going,
I'm not wanting to talk. I,
I kinda like getting in and
getting involved myself with guys,
especially like Miranda who I personally
believe it harder than a triple g
really? But yeah. And
I was a guy in there,
but that was my strategy as we're Canelo.
I wasn't,
I really wasn't a great strategy,
you know,
I didn't lay on the ropes
and let them around. Uh,
do you think he just didn't know what
to expect until he was in there with
triple gene? It could have been
because everything changes.
Like I think Mike Tyson said it,
you know,
everybody's got a game plan until they
get hit. Uh, he might've got touched,
like I said,
even what the tension and that Mayweather
fight and the whole brain might have
just started going a thousand miles
an hour trying to figure out, okay,
like this ain't going to probably work
tonight with this guy because he's a lot
stronger than I expected. And he was
just trying to maybe tire them out.
The only issue is now you're,
when you're on the ropes like that and
you're getting hit by a guy that hits
that hard and adults in the elbow
and the forearms and to the body,
and then you're,
you're tightening up and you're tensing
up really hard and you're cutting the
oxygen off to the blood. It tires you out
quicker and it wears you down. You know,
more than what he was doing in the
middle of the ring by pop shot and, and,
and counter punching. And he could have
dictated how fast he wanted. You know,
how much you wanted to punch all
hard. He wanted to punch. Yeah.
We certainly made some big improvements in
that second fight. Yeah. Do you, um, you,
you, you really don't want to see them
fight a third time? I truly don't.
I mean if it happens, I'm going to watch
it, you know, but they're going to fight.
Right.
I mean Canelo's obviously going to fight
some people and triple g is obviously
going to continue fighting.
You don't, and again,
I don't know how long triple g's going
to fight because as you mentioned,
and I agree with you, um,
I think he's starting to,
his age is showing up a little
bit with him. Wow. I, he,
he got avoided by a lot of people and we,
you know,
when he had a paper view a couple of
years back that only got 150,000 buys.
And I remember thinking that is a damn
shame damn shame that people don't
realize that this is absolutely
one of the best fighters ever.
I was surprised by that too,
cause I think he's a lot more
popular than what those numbers show.
I didn't get it. I don't
understand. I mean I don't,
maybe it's because they didn't think the
fight was competitive. Maybe. I mean,
maybe I don't know what it was,
but it just, it seemed like,
I just think personally myself, there's
a lot of flights out there for Canelo.
He just went up to one 68.
Yeah. I'm not a big fan of that.
I think he's too small for 16.
I do.
Especially if you get in with the right
flight or I truly do believe that,
you know, everybody, how tall is easy?
Five ten five, nine, five 10. Um,
but you know what, boxing or like
football, when you see the height,
you always got to take an inch, inch
and a half off to, so how did they lie?
Had me list is six three I'm right
under six. Two by like that much.
So it's kind of like the football program
and high school. Right, right, right.
But um, Canelo I think that there's
guys out there staying at 68.
It's kind of dangerous.
I think he's great and I'll tell it to
enough to keep good fights out there.
Yeah.
But it's a little dangerous in my opinion.
I think it 68 could
cause problems for them.
You got even the guys like Zardoz
Benevidez those are dangerous fights.
Just them two guys right there.
I would have to take not
so much overall skill wise,
just size and being at that
weight and you know, um,
you got guys coming down like
be evil from one 75 to one 68.
I think that his better days are
going to be at one 60. You know,
does he have a hard time making 60 or
do you just have an opportunity to fight
68 and he took it, I think
it's the trophies, you know,
and I don't blame him for that and either
he had the right flight to go up to
one 68 so we'll get another weight
division under his belt. Yeah.
He knows tuning in that dude up and I
think that would be what, three now?
He's a three week class
champ. Yeah. And uh, so that,
it looks good on paper when
you retire. Yeah, it does.
I would have done it if I
could have, you know, if there,
if there was the right fights out there.
But when he fought Mayweather Mayweather,
it made them cut down to what,
52 was it something like that.
I think the idea there were how to
catch weight around that, you know, um,
that fight was to me,
while it was a good learning experience
for him to be in there with a guy who
was as slick as Floyd is,
but also a good learning experience.
So you're not supposed to suck
that much weight out of your body.
Just he didn't have the fire.
No.
Even though you have a 24 hours or
however long it is to try to rehydrate,
that's never enough time
to recoup. Yeah. So your,
your thing is you're just hoping your
opponent's going through the same thing
that you are, you know,
that's what it comes down to.
What I do like about boxing that is
missing in MMA is more weight classes.
I really think that,
and that's one of the things that
people have a problem with inboxing.
They think there's too many weight
classes. I don't agree with that.
I think if anything,
there's too many world champions.
I think it's ridiculous that in
any organization that one guy
could be a WBC world champion.
The other guy could be a waa. There's an
Ibf is the WBO. I mean like that's crazy.
It's crazy to have that many world
champions. It should be a world champion.
But how do you decide what organization
is the real sanctioning body while you
just need one sanctioning body?
Uh,
I don't know how you would do that
either because it's all money.
You know what I mean?
There are so corrupt. Yeah.
It's all money is hard to do that. I,
I see your point on that a little bit.
And then I also look at like, you got
so many guys that are so good. Yeah.
And boxing is a short window.
So like how long can you stay on to it
until you finally get that chance to
fight the top guy?
Top Dog.
And anything can happen in boxing
too, you know? Uh, I, I kinda like,
I may maybe knock it down at three,
but I think when you have
the different way classes,
now you got four people just
say one person has each belt,
you got four world champs,
now you're looking at these four guys
and you can start taking these price
prospects.
And I started saying this will be an
interesting fight with this guy and this
guy and then I,
I do believe that they should make,
make happen one undisputed
champ. Yeah, I believe so too.
I think that should happen
in every week class.
They should have a fight off or a box
off and a four champions or you know,
maybe that way keep the prospect's in line
and have the four champions fight off,
you know, who's the undisputed champion
and then your prospects get your shot.
You know, it just seems weird to
have more than one world champion.
You're either the world champions like
how many guys won the Superbowl this year?
How many teams? One. One,
it should be one. No,
can't have multiple world champion.
Like when Anthony Joshua was walking
around as a heavyweight champion,
but also Deontay wilder is walking around
is the heavyweight champion. Like what,
what is this?
Are you the heavyweight champion or you
the champion of the organization that
falls into like what kind of,
again,
what we were talking about earlier
with the Jermaine Taylor thing when he
vacated the belts. Okay. Yeah.
In my mind you want the unified ton of
fire or universal recognizable the ring
middleweight title because where does
the lineal begin? When does it not?
And I had to ring title.
So usually in most cases during
cuddle is undisputed or Lenneal champ,
just so in other words, d Champa that
way class, you know, it's something,
but for the most part, you know, who is
the champion of a weight class? Well,
ring magazine's title is almost as
valuable as anybody else's. That's one.
And that's the one that I really
showcase when I show people my my case.
You know,
it's so classic too with like the,
the stripes and I think rocky really
did a lot for it. I bought two.
I do. That's true. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well,
it's a classy look at belt, you know,
and everybody else has got the big ones
with the leather and the strap like the
ring magazines. A nice one. Yup.
I wanted to belts, you know,
I didn't want to pay to sanction and fees
for all four to belts, but I wanted to,
I still wanted to Ibf and a WPA and um,
you don't have to put in the trophy case,
but uh, fortunately lot of fights
filter when you were up, um,
when you were a kid and you're
watching boxing where Yo Hagler fan,
I was a Hagler Fan,
but you know,
that's another one that's actually where
we may even have them guys like Manzini
in a Roya from Youngstown
and guys like that.
I had never really had this
one person that I was like,
or a poster in my bedroom, you
know, like deloit or something.
You never had one guy that like you
emulated or you were really little.
I emulated everybody and I think that's
what helped me get to this far as I did
in my career. I mean, even when I was 16,
I could watch a nine year old sparring
and see him do something cool.
It hit a guy and I'd be like, Damn,
you know, I'm going to try that. That,
that actually might work.
I followed it and I was just a
big fan of the sport overall.
Of course I had guys
that like, like God, he,
because of his style coming up and de
la Hoya Sugar Ray Leonard in my opinion,
is probably the one of the best fighters
pound for pound of all time. Um,
and it's arguable.
I mean if somebody says May,
whether I'm not going to say
one of the best for sure. Yeah.
I'm not going to say you're stupid for
having a number one. It's a great debate.
Um, but yeah, so I followed
it more as a fan, you know,
and I watched and I took from this
person I took from that person. We have,
as I mentioned,
we have some prospects in the amateurs
coming up that train in the same gym and
I would kind of copy their
style, you know, coming up.
So I was always trying to keep learning.
Like I even doing,
working out now I find different things
that work, you know, and what don't work.
And uh, that's what I did as far as box.
And I just watched guys I heroin there,
I have a copy for like two days
de la Hoya style, you know,
he'd be there with their hands up
and picking them off with the hands.
I go to [inaudible].
I didn't try it in a fight.
I did it in sparring and I will copy his
style a little bit to see how it works
or how I could add it to my arsenal.
So yeah,
I was just asking about Haggar because
he's sort of the quintessential middle
weight champion.
You know,
there's like a few guys that you look
back in the day and you look at who were
just iconic middleweight champion your
guys in your late forties and 50s.
Okay. They'll argue with you that he
was the best middle weight of all time.
He certainly was one of them. Yeah. And
you'll have, you'll have your guys that,
you know, have Hopkins. Uh, so
that's, that's what I'm saying,
like even the heavyweights,
you got your holders. Oh,
Joe Muhammad Ali was the best.
Then you have your guys and early
forties told you that Mike Tyson.
So it's kind of like whoever
grew up on that. Me Personally,
you've got to get past that because again,
that becomes biased and everybody's going
to kind of go with what they grew up
with. Um, there was a lot of greats.
Sure. Well, people sleep on Lennox Lewis.
He was, you know, when you
talk about the greats all time,
great heavyweight boxers,
like how the fuck do you not
include Lennox Lewis this
size, the size, the power.
Know. How do you not put Evander Holyfield
you do, you know guys that beat Tyson,
the crazy Riddick Bowe I mean,
we're way smaller than when I was a
helping Arrow called heavyweights right
there. Crazy era. Yeah, it was the
nineties. Right. And those are the ones,
when you say heavyweight division, those
were the fighters, you know, but it's,
how long ago was that now? You know,
a long time. Some years. And uh,
so it don't around enough.
Well, what I'm hoping is more emerging
town in the heavyweight division.
We'll sort of take a little bit of this
spotlight that you're seeing now that's
going on fury and wilder and Joshua
and I'd like to see and you know,
a little bit of our teas.
I like to see more guys get in the mix
there and have it be like it used to be
back then where there are a bunch
of like really exciting contenders.
He looked forward to these big fights
because right now there's like four guys,
five, six guys at most that
are going to fight each other.
Exactly. And you know, hopefully what
it does is it gets these other bigger,
bigger guys. He's at the athletic
athletes and, and uh, skilled athletes.
It hopefully it brings him
into the boxing again. Did I?
Did I remember this is David tool
making a comeback? I hope not.
Seriously. How old is he? Shit.
He gotta be mid forties dude.
He was 46 want,
maybe it's not, did I make that up that
he's making a comeback? I'm looking to,
he was a fucking monster.
Fortunately in the heavyweight division,
he probably could get away with
that f 46 I might be able to.
He was a god Damn Monster.
Uh, well he was short. He was,
he was a hard guy to fight. He was one
of them guys that low to the ground.
Thick, bigger legs. No neck.
Brutal power. Yeah. Good left hook.
Yeah.
He's the one who guides you didn't want
to fight even if you were Lennox Lewis,
his height. Remember when he knocked out
John Ruiz? Yeah. It was brutal. Yeah. No,
he was an animal man and he could take
a shot too. Remember when he fought a I?
Kobe a Buchi who was the only guy to
go the distance with a bay of Gucci.
I was another big, he was
a scary motherfucker. Yeah.
And what did he went to jail for?
Like sexual assault or something crazy
like that. He was in jail for a long time.
We were just talking about another guy to
kind of remind me of the Ummah. Samuel.
Peter's another. Oh yeah,
neck thick. Yeah, he was my,
I actually, I trained with him a
little bit out a top ranks gym. Um,
when we were fighting. He was
actually a really cool guy, you know,
and it was a big fan of mine too,
so it was kind of neat to be able to
share it out with him and you know,
talk with them before we started
training. That's cool. That's cool.
And Bay of Gucci, I think. I want
to say that he's getting out soon.
He was in jail for all long time and
apparently there was some article that I
read a couple of years back that he was
planning on making a comeback when he
gets released. But again, he's
deep into his forties as well.
And it's hard to make it come back and
no matter if it's heavy weight or not at
that level,
you don't have to be an hour.
I tell people all the time with even
young kids that are 21 and 22 when it,
sometimes these promoters,
freezer contractors is a dispute
going on and they sit out two years.
Sometimes they may not ever come back
fully from that. You know what I mean?
It's true. Especially at that high
of a level, you know, in boxing.
Did Mikey Garcia have a
contract as you did time? Yeah,
and I was concerned about that
when he came back. You know, I was,
I was concerned about how much
damage that time off could have done.
How long was this contract as people,
I think it was two over two years
for a top level fighter like him.
That's a disastrous is and you know,
but Mikey on the other hand is
a genius and a ring and he just,
he has that going for him, you know?
And uh, he also could fight, you know,
does he's been doing it since he
was so young and being in a family.
I think the cake came out to
Boone with boxing gloves on.
So there's so many good fights to
be made right now. It's just a,
it's a really exciting time. It's just a
really, really exciting time, which is,
you know, another reason why I'm bummed
out that HBO got out of the game.
I would like to see HBO come back.
I mean do you notice talks of it and uh,
I think it would be great for the sport.
Again,
if it came back as big as it did now
don't get me wrong towards the end.
And it was kind of hard to watch with
some of the fights they had on in my
opinion. You know, it just weren't
interesting. They weren't big fights.
Um, you know, and I think
that was a funding thing.
Like they didn't have
enough of a budget that,
or I think they knew longer that day
was so they were on the way out. Yeah.
And saved them money.
You know,
I don't know how many subscriptions
they lost from that. I,
I don't know if it hurt or what,
but I asked why I say I,
if they're keeping the fight game open,
an Arrow showing that I see coming back,
especially if showtime stays with the
boxing and doing as big as they are in a
box office with the, the numbers I see
Hbo, I think it would have to come back.
Well, I think with things like
Netflix and Amazon prime, they're,
they're making these television shows
now that are so popular and they,
there's such high budget,
but you get things like game of
Thrones cost so much money to make,
but so many people watch it.
I think they're concentrating on
those kind of things cause they're so
profitable. And I don't think
it's the networks anymore.
I got worry about shutting down to
with all these other, uh, Zulu and,
and Amazon and Netflix being out,
you know, I think some of the,
eventually somebody cable companies are
going to have to worry. Yeah. You know,
I'm sure. Yeah. It seems
like, you know, it's,
we're entering into a new era
of entertainment technology
and the advancement of
it, you know, again, these apps people,
I think that ESPN plus had over 7 million
some a subscribers when it came out
because of the boxing and
everything else and that,
that does own does the u s or you
know, flights on there and uh, boxing.
So you're going to have these coming out
and people were going to get into it.
And it's, it's changing. It's changing a
lot. Well, they're doing Beltour fights.
They're doing a lot of fights on
disown. Right? Yeah. Yeah. It's, um,
it's very exciting time. You
thought about you, you were saying,
talking a little bit about commentary.
If you thought about doing commentary.
I have, have you ever done
any of it? No. No, no. But,
uh, I would like to, you know,
honestly, I, I would, uh,
I not knocking anybody.
I may not be the best
talker in the road either,
but I listened to some of the
guys on there and I'm like,
I think I could do that. You know,
listen, I know you can do it.
You definitely do it.
Um,
but to me it adds a certain
element when a real world class,
um, is breaking down situations cause
you're getting to see it from their
perspective of how they would approach it.
It's not just a guy who's
a boxing experts, a guy who
did it, who did it. Yeah.
A guy who was a world champion like
Andre Ward. Like when Andre Ward's on,
I fucking love that guy as a commentator.
Yeah. All is good to Paulie's Andrei.
And Pauline is mal analogies. One
of my favorites. He's excellent.
Damn that motherfucker
talks good fro times.
Mala noche a little bit,
just said a lot is smart as shit man.
He is,
he's a and all aspects of life, you
know, he's doing well for himself and uh,
he does the right things. So Paulie's
is a great person. I like him.
He's a good buddy of mine.
And uh, yeah, it is. You know,
I think when the fans
like to watch and see,
you [inaudible] want to hear from the
historian or to guide as the other
commentator who just knows the
sport and who can speak well.
They lay care in north side of it.
Yes.
But I think at some certain times during
a fight they like to hear from the
fight or like, Hey, what the hell
is going through that guy's mind?
He just got smashed, you
know, with that right hand.
Or you get hit with a good body shot
and why does this keep happening again?
Why is, why is he doing this?
What's going on with the flutter?
Thinks should be set in a corner.
You know, they're in between rounds.
So I think it's important to
have a guy that's been there,
done it as a commentator.
Andre Ward is another interesting guy
because he's also young and also world
champion undefeated and just decided,
you know what, I'm good. See Ya.
He is,
he is a right now.
It actually is funny and I'm going to
have to talk about it a little bit.
We were at, I was covering a fight,
the Loma Chanko per draws a fight.
And he comes up to me and I
don't know where, and he's
like, hey, you're like, damn,
you getting big. And he's smiling. He
shakes my hand and he walks down to,
you know,
covered a fight.
And I'm sitting there and look at watching
the fights and then I'm getting ready
to head out after, you
know, the fights about over.
And he comes walking up and he goes,
hey, if the offered you $10 million,
would you make a come
back? I'm like, fuck you.
I couldn't find a reason why I wasn't.
Um, I don't know. And he won't.
He smiled and he walked away and I was
going, I'm scratching my head, I'm going,
I wonder why. You know why he would
ask me a question like that. Yeah.
I seen recently that he's looking at as
certain fighters as a possible comeback.
Oh, so he's thinking about doing
it again? Yeah. Yeah, it is.
It's so real.
It's so itchy.
I just don't think you're ever going to
find anything that's going to recreate
the highs of like when you
knocked out Tremaine tailor.
How the fuck could you recreate
that high? You can't. You can't.
That combination when you pin them in
the corner and put them away and then you
walk away and you realize that you one
holy shit and that don't even kick it
ness all going a hundred miles an hour,
you're up on that.
I see the pictures all the time,
all that up with the hands in the air and
I see all the people and you know that
that's just, it was so
fast, you know? It took me
wow. Before I could, I even know I walked
back out of my house and I had him up.
You know on the side, this was before I
still live with my parents at the time.
And I did too.
I had a pulpit at the house and I'd be
leaving to go to the gym or something and
I look over at the boats and um, I go,
wow, you know what? Those are mine.
But it never really kicked in until
like a little while later. Like,
those are my fucking boats. You don't
like add that I did that. That I'm,
I'm the role champion. Not only I've
got one, but I got three of them.
When you're lying in bed that night,
you probably had to be going, well,
what am I in a fucking dream? That's what
it felt like. It is. What fight this was.
God Damn,
this was a fight.
This was one of my all time favorite
middleweight championship fights for sure.
And Jermaine Taylor, man, he
was a bad motherfucker. He
wasn't. And again, you know,
a lot of people talked about the handful
of flights before that and a tough,
you know, with smaller guys, but he was
a bronze medalist who beat, you know,
demand Bernard Hopkins.
There.
It is doom the combination
when you put them away too.
Fucking phenomenal man.
Phenomenal.
This right here when you want it was
all bore. I just put my hands up.
Yup. Fuck man. I mean
what that feeling like?
Try to describe that.
Like what is going through your head?
Everything possible for
him not to get back up.
And I know it sounds funny when people
say that, but that's the truth. You know,
my big thing was if I got somebody hurt,
get them out because boxing
is dangerous. Right. You know,
and anything can happen
and they could get back up.
They have a chance that knocking
you out or beaten you. So,
but when it was over, like what does that
feel like? It's, it's hard to explain it.
It really is. You're just,
you're, you're on cloud nine,
you just not naked bring you down.
You know, you're, you're, uh,
you went from being a proud open means
is through the roof to be in a world
champion. To be in a huge
superstar unboxing. Yeah.
And it's hard to grasp at
once and it takes time.
And unfortunately sometimes you get it
when it's too late. You know what I mean?
You really grasp it and it's just one
of them things. It's, you know, even,
I was talking with a guy
last night and he brought up,
he was originally from South
Korea and he was talking about,
he goes there all the time, big
business guy and he says, uh,
they actually just studied my fight down
or something on how you can get knocked
down. This is more of, you know,
in your field of up your alley,
how you get knocked down to
what gets a guy to get back up.
Every cover to recovery,
the endurance to pretty much
have your brain's rattled,
but be able to come back that strong
Brown's later and knock somebody out,
you know? And for me to support answer
is, you know, of course training hard,
you know, making sure I'm in shape, but
I guess what he's trying to figure out,
I was like, what's, what's the,
the brainwave pattern wise said,
what's the drive that gets you to do that?
What is the endurance of the muscles?
And you know, that's pretty
deep thinking and a little pass.
I think there's a lot there.
There's a lot, and there's no one.
First of all, every combination that you
get hit with is different. You know, some,
some combinations you're just not going
to get up from. And some of them you,
you were on the border. Can
you get up? Can you not get
up? How bad do you want it?
Maybe think about your daughter.
Maybe you think about your mom and you
just kept this burst of adrenaline and
you're like, fuck this. I'm getting up.
And the referee gives you the count.
He just fight smart.
Keep your hands up and keep moving.
The next thing you know that cardio kicks
in and then you're back at Tyson fury.
That's the way I looked at it. That's
like the simple way of looking at it.
Tyson fury against wilder. By all
rights, that fight should have been done.
He lands that right hand and then that
left hook and you see Tyson fewer go
down. Like he got hit in the
head with an asteroid. Boom.
He's just flat on his back.
Like Holy Shit.
He knocked him out in the 12th round
and then everybody thought he did the
undertaker. He sat up. Yes. You know what?
I like memes and gifs of him sitting
up and like they showed the undertaker
doing it with that right there.
I think a little different from mine.
I personally believe that he
wasn't hurt that bad. Really.
I believe that he got dropped it.
That was legit,
but he was laying there taking
the eight, nine seconds, you know,
to recover and he got up.
I don't think he was out because
there's no real way to be out that cold.
I don't to get up,
get up and the hand of Jesus,
Jesus came down upon him. Man,
this watch that knocked down.
Pull up that knockdown. Yup. Um,
I feel like that was one of the
most fucking bizarre is my common.
We're talking about that as far as
like what's going through your head?
It's crazy because when I got knocked
down, it was more of an equilibrium shot.
But I could hear my legs were gone,
but I can hear a certain people in the
stands and I knew what was going on.
And the first thing that was in my head
was when you worked way too hard to go
out like this. So it is that
drive. Yeah, here it is right here.
What's crazy is that wilder,
look at this. Boom. I mean,
come on man. This dude, he's fun.
Fucking hurt. He's fucking
hurt. Something happened.
Jesus came down upon him. That's why
it's, that's why I was saying I think,
I don't know. Maybe he was hurt. I mean,
he went down, he went down pretty bad.
He wouldn't talk quick.
Incredible.
And then his ability to recover and the
fact that he's not the best in shape guy
either. You don't think so? Well, I mean
we kept moving for 12 fucking rallies.
Yeah, he did do that. But to be
able to get up that quick, well,
how was he not the best in shape guy?
I mean to be six foot. That's a funky,
crazy knocked out and then while that
does the sleazy gray shape for for a
heavyweight, you can put it that
way. I see what you're saying. Yeah.
Well no heavyweight is ever going to
be in the same kind of shape that say,
Oh yeah your weight's going to be in just
because you're carrying around so much
body weight.
But I was saying from the point of getting
up that quick after being dropped and
not to be stumbling and falling over.
It's true.
I mean he just came back and that's why
I'm thinking more so like yeah he got
hurt and I'm probably wrong on this,
but I'm saying like yeah he got hurt
and he's laying there and he's going to
shit, let me just, let's watch it.
Here it comes. That fucking missile
and then this one,
I mean come on son timber.
That's, that is some crazy shit.
They said he hit his head but he did not.
I let them, people say he hit his head,
bounced off the Mat, it never
bounced off the mat. He,
he kept his head up as he was going back,
which lets you know that he was
conscious but doom and Bob boom.
I mean he got fucking rocked,
but I wish they would've had an overview
because you could tell by the eyes also.
Right,
right.
Whether or not the rolled back in his
head to the side cardio is significant.
If you're in great cardio shape, you
recover quicker. You know there's,
there's a bunch of different
factors in why you recover quicker.
Your mindset has to play a factor.
Right. How bad you want it.
That's what I'm saying.
I mean,
no doubt he was hurt from
that bunch and he went down.
I was just thinking for that period of
time was he laying her also saying I'm
going to take the full eight and nine
to get up or like you said, did a,
did a hand come down upon him
and rose from the dead. Yup.
He's just a tough motherfucker man. And
a good guy too. Super fucking smart guy.
Funny. Yeah. I mean, what a character.
And now when you were training
and you were doing yours,
your strength and conditioning,
did you,
will you like an old school method guy
or did you use heart rate monitors and
all the new school methods?
No, I was, I, I liked the, uh,
functional shrank training.
I did a lot of that.
What kind of stuff?
I do a sledge hammer and tire pushing.
Matt Brown, uh, has a, a great, uh,
he's got a, what is Matt's company?
Give us his company a plug.
I think it's a immortal something
strength and conditioning,
but he's got a great bunch of, uh, um,
he's got sledge hammers but with a
rounded head so you don't have to fucking
swinging around and uh, and mortal combat
equipment, mortal combat equipment.
He's got a great sled to
the stack weights on and uh,
he left a lot of that stuff
out there. These grip. Yeah,
the war wagon. A lot of uh,
different, uh, grip
strength, the apparatus,
things like balls at you, uh, do chin ups
for those, those balls on the far left.
You do a chin up script. And those
things. Yeah, it's got some great shit.
Those slopes depths pushing,
pushing a trucks. Um,
and what else did we get into it?
I would go to this place called ironman
warehouse and it was kind of a nice
setup there too. And it was more
for like the, the, the gym owner.
I love him to death and he is crazy.
He truly is.
And he's about 48 now and he could still
Rondi runs with a matter of fact at the,
my role title fight against
Taylor at the boardwalk.
Everybody kept talking about,
we were like 4,000 people talking about
this crazy guy running on a beach.
But I think the log was like 120 pounds
just running. You don't want to stop.
Yeah. Real Christian Guy, you
know, intuit and he does all that.
He runs all the piece races with
that. Um, phenomenal shape. It,
well you had a place down in [inaudible]
was the functional strength training.
You know, I do pull ups on fire hoses
and put a gripping and everything else.
That's why I like Joe. And that was, you
know, cause I wasn't building muscle. Um,
but I was getting strong as hell and I
was getting also a lot of cardio work
involved in that. But for the
most part it was the, uh, the,
the sres. Yeah, the Roman road.
A log on here is this motherfucker
running around with a log that can be good
for your names. I wonder how he's
walking right now. Like right now,
I see guys do screw, screw,
screw, shit like that. I go, okay,
you can do that right now, but let me
see what you look like in six months.
Let me call you back. I'm gonna
call you doing it for a long time.
I don't know how he does it.
That's so much weight on your joints to
be running with 120 pound log on your
shoulders is a freaking nature.
What does that show?
The Ninja Warrior or whatever.
I truly believed that he could go into
that and do very well on that. I mean,
he had to,
at the ironman warehouse,
they had the little balls and he
swings from each one up there. Uh,
he takes the 45 pound plates,
he throws them up in the air and
it catches them back coming down.
Just crazy things like that.
And that's where I went to
train after the Miranda fight.
I was doing all that shit on
my own for the Miranda fight.
And then after the Miranda, he
had told me, he goes, Kelly,
I got this place down here.
Come down and try it out.
And I was doing all that crazy stuff, man.
And it worked it again. That was strong.
The only thing that I wish I
could have went back with that,
and now as time goes on and I'm
training some athletes at my gym,
is we have this machine called a Virta
backs PC equipment. And it's amazing.
I mean, it truly is. You could emulate,
um, more so than you can with the bands.
What you're doing. If you're
a football player, you know,
you want to come off Verdun Max Max is,
it's an amazing clinic for a rest.
Right? There is for wrestlers,
is it,
are these bands like elastic
button but as okay as no straps.
Okay.
With the rubber band you,
your attention is usually gone at the
beginning and then get to get to a certain
point to get it as where this has
resistance all the way through. Oh,
police system.
It is a pulley system and you can set
the tension on it on the back part.
You could pull out and make it
a little harder. The tension,
but it's unbelievable.
So when you go back down there's tension
all the way through from beginning to
end fast twitch muscle and um,
a lot of wrestlers are
using it. Ooh, I like that.
So I wish they had that because a lot
adding that in with the functional
strength training could have
definitely made a me a lot better.
And I think it could
for a lot of athletes.
That seems like you could do everything
with that thing. Yup. That's amazing.
They had the wrap there also, which is
very good. It's the same concept as that,
but you put it up on a fence
and you could run out farther,
do different things on the raptor.
Also would that thing,
could you do like shoulder exercises
and stuff like that as well?
You just have to prop it up.
I've been screwing around with it at
my gym and I found ways to do flies on
putting a little, um, balance boards.
I put that down on it and I can get
the straps where you could do flies.
What a shoulder exercise at core.
You know, especially with the raptor,
you could walk out with that. And what is
the raptor? It goes on the wall. You can,
it's more for like travel,
see if you find that thing.
So you could put it on the fence
at a baseball field and just swing.
You could even do a Gulf street is
right there. Yeah. Verdun Max Raptor.
Uh, wow. Look at called the golf swing.
And can you adjust the tension? Yes.
Is this on the back? So you'll pull it,
they have little black spots that uh,
tell you, you know, it goes up to three,
three spots. So that seems like that'd be
great for punching power as well. It is.
And the thing is, you don't want too much
tension with that. I tried to explain,
I got some people that work with the guys
at my gym on it and they trained them
more like an endurance thing. And I
tell him, you're defeating the purpose,
you know, there, there's a place in time
for strength and endurance socially,
a boxer, a guys running in the morning,
he's sitting pads at the gym. You had,
I really think that should be focused on
the explosion. Don't go to your chair.
You're tired. I want every rep,
every movement to have explosion.
Roy Jones Jr. Yeah, yeah. That's amazing.
So you just,
uh,
it's just enough resistance so that
everything that you do just get too much
resistance and you're not going to be
able to really fire off the fast twitch.
Right. Right. Now,
the only thing I see also that could hurt
people is that they do a whole workout
with that Dow.
What happens?
You eventually get tired and fatigued
and then all your motion is slow.
So now you fall into a habit of
that. You know, I like to work,
I'm on it for about 15, 20 minutes. Um,
take them off and then have them do the
same exercises with it after what? No,
no resistance.
And then it just keep it that day
just with the fast twitch muscle,
the small muscle training.
And then the next day we go into strength
or endurance. So are you training guys?
I'm right now passing on
this. Jim and I have a, yeah.
And I have one box and
the name of your gym.
My Gym and was called Mine and my
gym. So we had, we had changed. Yeah.
Because I've already had my gym. And
why Jim [inaudible]. Jim, yeah, me, Jim,
Jim. Come on down to the
gym by the Spanish my, yeah,
or at a time. Yeah, no, we got, uh,
I'm doing that with them right now.
It's fun working with a strength.
And conditioning, you know,
I am also going to be doing a boxing
gym at the end of the summer, hopefully.
And it's going to happen. It's
just a matter of time. Now,
when you were training
and you were fighting, um,
did you have a specific schedule of when
you would do strength and conditioning
and how many days a week you would run?
How many days a week you would do like
physical exercises. Yeah. You know,
and that's another thing. You
all, as I've said earlier too,
you always keep learning, you
know, and it was never, I wasn't,
it worked for me for what I did when I
was fighting and that would totally have
it now
knowing the stuff that I know and,
and you know, being involved in it,
researching and, um, you know, we used
to run Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
three miles, and then take Thursday off
on Friday and Saturday. And then we do,
on top of that,
I would go to your,
my strength and conditioning training
and now we've got the boxing gym.
That's a lot. Yeah, that's a lot on the
body too. And, um, you know, as we're,
like when I went to California,
we did Monday, Wednesday,
Friday running and it was only
two and a half, three miles.
And then in those days in between we did
a strength and conditioning training.
Um, so I didn't have a preference
on that. I didn't care. Um,
the only thing I did say is I didn't
want to run early in the morning.
Why is that?
Because I didn't get going.
I wasn't one of those guys in the morning
and it happens to people, you know,
like if I wouldn't ran too early,
I would end up being the film like shit
the rest of the day really you got,
you know,
like it was just dragging ass as where
when I went and ran at like nine 30 in
the morning,
I got my best run,
I killed it and then I felt
great the rest of the day. What,
how much sleep would you make sure
you had? That was a tough one.
I got about seven to eight hours.
Yeah.
They say you need eight and you really
should try to get 10 when you're a
professional athlete.
I took my Sundays off and,
and I rested all day Sunday
and that kind of aid, you know,
a good amount of carbs and kind of what
I wanted to on, on Sundays, you know,
depending on where to wait was out, how
far out we were from to fight. But um,
I don't,
I really don't believe in the theory of
you got to wake your guy up at four in
the morning and make them run.
I don't if I was training guys,
I want my guy to run out whatever
I'm going to get the best run out of.
That's what time I want him to run.
He'll adapt and especially after he
keeps fighting and he'll adapt this more
mind over body.
Um,
but I think the gym is not negotiable.
Three o'clock I like to train and
if I was trading guys, my Gemara,
it would be between three and seven.
Why do you like late afternoons?
Because it gets you closer to the fight
night, especially closer to a fight.
I would like to actually from my guys
and train about eight o'clock at night,
nine o'clock depending on what they have
and are going on in a personal life.
So you have like a clock so your body
has like a time that it knows it's going
to work and I didn't do that.
What did you do? I sparred,
you know for three but if I'm talking
about me being a trainer I would like that
for my fighters. So what you've learned
from your career, you just apply it? Yeah.
The only thing I would really take from
it would be the running in the morning.
You know,
if my guy want to said hey coach,
I'd rather run after the gym tonight
and I knew that that was going to make a
difference in a minute on his mouth.
Okay.
Run at night cause I want them
to get the best run. Pause.
That's the most important. So did you
run for speed? Did you do sprints?
Did you do long distance running? Like
what did, what kind of running did you do?
I did do sprints. We added, I wish
we could've done more, but you know,
I was big with the uh, steps
to and we have ours. Yeah.
Youngstown State University and Youngstown
and it got one side that's pretty big
as steep,
you know,
and it goes up and I would do that
probably about three times at Camp for
unbeliever believer,
you've got to watch how many times you
do that throughout a camp because it
builds muscle, especially running
that high, you know, down the steps.
And then when you start cutting
to wait and you got to get down,
this is going to be hard
to lose that extra pound,
which could make a big
difference. Come fight night.
So for a six, eight week camp,
you would only run it three times,
three times interested.
Then I had sprints on the hills and
I did regular sprints because regular
sprints is firing that fast twitch muscle
and is also hitting a big muscle in
his building. The legs and, and strength.
Um, distance was, was important,
but still another big one to
me is the pad work. You know,
the training at the gym.
I'm not a big fan of bag work.
Anybody hitting the punching bag?
How come?
Because you learn how to
manipulate the bag of trick your,
your trainer and everybody else.
I can go ahead and bag right now.
I probably do 10 rounds on it, you know,
just because I know how hard to punch.
It's hard to tell us to worry
when you're hitting pads.
I know how hard my guys punching and I'm
giving him the combos in a numbers so
he has to concentrate on what you want
them to do and he's not throwing the
punches that he wants. You know
what I mean? So it's easier.
I mean it's harder than it in the bag.
Um,
I think that's a big part of the
training. You know, that I would do it,
the guys and, and it's, it makes
a big difference overall. Um,
did you do like a lot of drills in
term in terms of like a movement trills
movement, drills with combinations? Like
how to not, not, not at home either.
You know, I didn't when I
trained in a young stone. No, no.
I learned a lot of that. You know, when
I went to California from Garcia. Yeah.
So that was that one of the reasons
why you were saying like, man,
it was amazing that I can learn.
Cause you know,
I was cocky and I'm going to fuck,
they going to show me after 12 years of
being pros and awesome trainer. Yeah.
You know, I was cocky. What?
I'm like, I got all of these
fights and I was, you know,
great amateur, what more can you show
me? And I went out there and I learned,
you know, you can't be taught and uh,
taking nothing away from, you know,
Jack and my trainer at home. I mean
that guy, he got me ready though.
Like if you're fighting,
I was in shape, you know,
it was like a drill sergeant on that.
And you'll have another little thing on
that which of running, you know, submit.
I think now I would have my guys
run on grass track was boring.
I don't care if you're bored running,
you know,
you're going to run around a track.
It's easier on the joints and
a lusty man on the body. But,
uh, so overall, I mean there's
a lot. That's why I like it.
That's why I like being involved right
now with the strength and conditioning
gym because I'm working with people,
getting them healthy, helping them out,
and eventually I could add a lot of
this to my fighters, you know? Yeah.
There's a long education when it comes
to physical fitness, the long education,
understanding how much is too much,
when's the right time to do things.
And that's one of the
reasons why I was asking you,
like how did you decide if you're going
to do three times over the course of a,
um, a training camp, you're going to run
those stairs. How did you decide that?
Was that a strength conditioning
coach at the side of that? No,
that was just because, yes, cause
I didn't want it. The muscle,
I knew where he come and
wait on you. Yeah. Yeah.
A couple times when when
you're starting to dry out,
you're going to wish
that you kind of didn't.
But I always was afraid of the back that,
you know, of the second guessing my,
my conditioning. So I always
wanted to be strong, you know,
and again that the stuff like that
Verda Max that wasn't out yet. You know,
we had the bands and we do
some of the exercises on that.
I had never researched
much at that time either.
I was in great shape and
I was strong as a mule,
but there was other things
like being athletic,
I started eventually towards the
end doing some cross training.
You said you're a big fan of
that. Yeah, I absolutely am. Also,
I think becoming a great athlete overall.
There's nothing wrong
with that and it's fun.
It breaks up the monotony of the
same training regimen all the time.
Do you remember when they
didn't want you to lift weights?
They didn't want boxers to lift weights
before Mackey, she'll stone, uh,
before he worked with um,
uh, Michael Spinks when he,
when he moved up to heavyweight
and fought Larry Holmes. I mean,
remember people were saying like,
they don't want boxers to lift weights,
that it's going to tighten you up
and slow you down. Like that was,
that was the thought process behind it.
And then from him and then in particular
Holyfield and Holyfield went from
cruiserweight to heavyweight
and he put on a lot of mass.
That was Mackey shields stone too,
right? Yeah. Yeah. I mean that,
that just changed the game.
Jamie.
That's your guy. But I don't want to
make them have to keep searching thing.
He loves it. They actually asked
if you could put in, um, yeah.
Kelly pelvic workout workouts.
A training. We had a guy to,
what's the wait, I did do weight lifting
when you were, when I was fighting. Yeah.
But I, and I do agree. What's the weight
lifting and I don't agree with it.
I don't think you should go heavy with
the weight lifting if you're going to get
your strength. I absolutely.
Um, look how thin you are, man.
Broad training. Slim bastard. Yeah.
Trey put a training with rock at
Rocky's or something like that.
That was California. Yeah.
There you go. That second one.
MMM.
Yeah, I see the lightweight. Yeah. Well
we would do hundreds and hundreds of reps.
Just endurance stuff. Burn, just burning.
When you look at yourself without
all the tattoos to go, Huh,
look at all that blank canvas.
Look at those arms. Yup.
But you look at those arms now you're
probably embarrassed it was gigantic.
Tree trunks are packing now. No. Yeah,
but those things kick ass those things.
Fuck your head up. Yeah, exactly.
I don't know if I had the snap on it
now like I had done, but um, so, so the,
the way stuff like that I totally agree
with because it is great for muscle
endurance if you're going
to get your strength.
I go back to the functional
training for that.
I don't think a boxer or a con bag,
it might be a little different with
Yossi Guy MMA fighters because of the
wrestling and wrestling and everything
else. And that will come down to having a,
somebody that really knows, like I said
it, he never stopped learning and it, um,
but for me, what my guys yet endurance
training like that. That's great.
And you could even switch that in.
What's some endurance
training to, you know, one thing
we used to do at ironman standard,
get a heavy chain and is locked out for
the front delts and turn it, turn it,
you know,
40 insurance do for a period of time.
So there's just a lot of things that
you could add in. I think, you know,
everybody goes, well,
you don't overtrain them.
And that's another thing like the body,
it's really hard to overtrain. I mean,
you could,
the only way you could really overtrain
as if you're not getting the right
nutrition and you're not getting
the right rest, you know? Um,
or if you push too hard,
you don't give yourself enough recovery
time and you push it too close to a
fight. Yeah. See that's too long and you
don't get enough rest period in between.
That's a big one.
Yeah.
The two long and camp, um, you know, Tim
Silvia or not Tim Silvia, Tim Kennedy,
who's a big, uh, who's for one
time at one point, he retired now,
but he was one of the top,
middle way contenders.
He went through two camps in a row
because one of his fights got canceled,
rolled right into a tech camp and then
fought and then had no endurance and his
fight, you could kind of tell that he was
drained. They just, it was just too long.
It was like seven, six or seven
months of really being in camp.
Something along those lines.
Probably in the, in the lines
of some word, the nutritionist,
it could come down on a, on a person like
that. Is he getting enough, you know,
the sources. It's also cutting
a lot of weight. Exactly.
So, you know, dehydration,
everything else. Yeah. Um, yeah.
It's, and it's hard. I mean,
you got to find if you're going to bring
somebody in. I was fortunate, my dad,
you know, we kinda kicked ass on that. We
had a little science brought, you know,
broken down to a science and uh, we,
we made weight good and we were strong.
Um, did you monitor your heart rate
ever? No. Never. Just felt how you felt.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
did you write down like how different
kinds of exercises you were doing?
Did you play? You played it off and I
still do that. I still put that into my,
even a weightlifting. Really? Yeah.
I feel like when you write down
your limit yourself, how so?
Because if I go in, I see guys all
the time, not knocking at everybody,
but I see them come in with a little
notepad and they have what they got and I
see him go over and do literally only
four sets on a bench and then they write
down what they did and then they go over
and do some dumbbells or same with the
squats. I feel you're
limiting yourself. I mean,
you didn't work that muscle to a,
you know,
failure then you should most
of the time because if not,
that becomes maintaining, you're not
breaking down the muscle fibers, you know,
unfortunate recoup. I feel,
you know, when you go and lift,
I'm not saying every Zach time you
got to kill it, but when I go in,
I want to do either a little bit heavier
or more reps than I did last time.
You know what I mean? For me to get to
the point where I want to get in it,
it has worked for me. Um, I, I do,
I feel like when you write down,
the only time I do write things
down is if I'm doing a chart,
I'll go through that chart.
And then when I finish what I finish
out with so many reps in that same
percentile of my PR, you know
what I mean? And I'll go down now,
then I have a speed day and endurance
day, what's it? And when I rubbed out,
and I do sometimes have to 300 reps,
you know,
on a body part and speed and endurance.
And then before I even do that,
I work on safe as bench or squat.
I get the bands and I have my guys do
no more to six reps and all gotta be
explosion because that helps empower lift,
lifting for.one rep Max.
You know what an explosion off
so it comes down, you know,
and that's my theory on it. And
a lot of people, you know, do it.
And then you got guys
who do write down though.
Do you think there's any benefit in the
kind of lifting that you're doing now
for a boxer? I think right now
if you have the time, yeah.
It could help you atomic in between if
you had time to get that big or get that
strong for maybe two months of heavy.
But I also think that you need a good
period of time of no heavy lifting to
recover before we start really boxing.
So your body's going to be used to it.
Muscle memory, you know, you'll still be,
you're not going to lose all
that strength because you're,
you're not just stopping to power
lifting and not doing anything.
You know what I mean? It seems like a real
guessing game. At least it experiment.
I wouldn't try it if I was active and
I had an active fighter. But yeah,
I would like to see somebody
try that eventually.
One day you never know what her to go,
always coming out with something or
they're always debunking some other,
you know, uh, you have to do this.
And my favorite thing is where
I get an about the training.
When people say you can't do this two
days a week, you can't bench or squat.
Look at your guy's in jail.
All they do every day. Yeah.
If I lift weights and eat shitty food,
they don't have the supplements
that we have. You know,
they can't take a protein
powder drink and bcas so,
and they're not small. They're huge.
You're jacked, you're lifting every day,
you know.
So
I don't know.
Well you familiar with Pavel Tot Salini?
Yes. Wasn't he the guy also with
the kettle bells or yeah. Yeah,
he's um, he's got some
interesting thoughts about, um,
about strength training in particular
because he's one of those guys that you,
he believes you should do
more rest in between reps, uh,
less reps and you should do it more often.
So instead of like one
brutal workout a week,
will you break your body down the walk?
Like you're getting fucked in the ass by
a rhino for two days. Instead of that,
you, you work out with less
repetitions. Don't go to failure,
but do it two or three times a week.
You get more repetitions overall
over the end of the week, but you'll,
you'll be able to recover better.
And you never get that full breakdown,
but your body gets just
as strong or stronger.
I seen that and I actually,
I was reading on that and that was
going to put that in, you know, uh,
put that into my program
and I read a lot of them.
I see like Semans would west side.
Um,
they got some great ideas and that's when
it comes to lift the weights and power
lift and there's only so much,
so somebody got it from somebody,
you know what I mean?
Like west side,
they were big with the Russian
Olympic team and everything else.
There's only so much you could do.
There's only so many programs you could
do where you're not tapping in and
copying off this person's. Um, I
think that in, there is nothing
wrong with that either. Now, not changing
it up after awhile in shotgun up body.
I think that actually helps
you get stronger, you know,
and changing the program a little
bit. But um, you know, if that works,
I don't know.
And that's something that I may try one
day because I'm doing power lifting,
but pilots and ain't going to
be my vacation home in Hawaii.
You just doing the power lifting for
a drink for fun. It was, you know,
it was something that was fun.
And uh,
I got guys who I've gotten involved with
a buddy of mine, actually a coach on,
you know, certain days of the week. We
work on a heavy Lonnie Atkins. He's great.
He's a like six, seven time world champion
power lifter and drug free, you know,
um,
federations like Ra and a WMP F and I,
and asked what I'm in because I feel like,
you know,
I have not, I'm not knocking the other
people that use the steroids and stuff,
but for me, I like going the
natural route and you know,
especially if you think about
fighting again, because if you do,
you don't want to fuck
up your endocrine system.
So that's where I really turned against
it also is because of the boxing.
You know what I mean? Um, I don't
want to make anybody too mad,
but when people would use it,
I feel like you're taking away.
And then I do feel like it's cheating. I
tell people in the gym, my gym, you know,
there are certain people in
our diet that do it and I,
and they try to come over and tell people
how to work out and this kind of like,
listen,
you're working out is totally different
than disguise and what you do to get big
as totally different all because of
that reason. Yeah, it is. It truly is.
And the power lifting,
he's actually,
and I got guys right now that are freaks
of nature that do it and you could tell
that they're not on it
because if they are, then he,
I thought long talk with her
dealer. Um, you know what I mean?
One of those type things. But, uh, I,
I like doing only because for me it's,
it's not cheating, you know? And
also I liked the fact of like,
when I hit a plateau,
I look,
it's more fun for me to go through and
research things and look at like how do I
get out of that and what's,
what's good nutrition that helps
naturally raise this or raised that,
you know what I mean? And different
workout routines, the board work chains,
you know, add that all in. So that's
where it comes fun for me also. Yeah.
Do you do, um, do you get your blood
work done or anything like that?
I did get a blood panel last, uh, last
year and was, yeah, that's it. Yeah.
And it can only get like normal ones,
regular ones. Kind of afraid to him, Hey,
I'm going, I'm getting to that age, you
know, I don't want that shit coming back
bad. You don't want to
know. Yeah. You know? Hell,
if I start filling it then I'll
go. But um, no, but you should too.
I recommend it to everybody and
not every athlete, you know,
they should and eventually my time
has to go back soon also. Yeah,
I think it's a really important thing.
I think everybody should do it
on a regular basis. I really do.
I know you don't want to know about
anything bad, but you do know,
but you have to, if there really was
something funky going on and you know,
you went to the doctor and the doctor's
like, Kelly, these, these numbers are bad.
This is, we gotta we gotta
do some more. Exactly.
Work more tests and see
what the fuck's happening.
Especially with all these different
diets that people were getting on.
I'm seeing, yeah. Horrific things
that I had a brother in law from, you
know, a certain diet that Kito Diet.
You know, what happened to him? Fatty
liver. A this, cause he's done it.
You don't drink. Yeah. Wow. That's fucked.
You know, diet, that's what I'm hearing.
Well, if you really look at it, I mean,
you're eating the fat, all that fat.
And sometimes it's for me. Yeah. But if
Jess, all your body got to burn, you know,
and your organs got to the,
what happens with people where it
does get dangerous is first of all,
if you have certain, uh,
certain genes, certain people,
it's just not the best diet for,
and it's,
it's a lot of trial and error to find out.
But it's also if you engage in a
high fat contact dot content diet,
but you also have high carbohydrate,
which is where a lot of people cheat
and fuck up, that's not good. That's,
that's not good for you. Like you,
you got to get your body into Ketosis,
into ketosis.
If you don't get your body into ketosis
and you're taking this high level of fat
and the car I love Oh carbs, it's
not, it's just not a good combination.
But it also has, you know, boards
to do on it. If you come off of it,
you can't just indulge into
the carbs either, right?
Don't you slowly work
that back into your body.
Always knows how to process carbs.
It's more difficult to
get your body fat adapted,
but once your body does get fat adapted.
But I've found is a,
I'm not on a ketogenic diet right
now, but when I've been on it, um,
I can get back in it pretty quick,
but it takes a while.
Like the first time I did it,
it took a solid two weeks
before I felt normal.
For two weeks I was dragging ass.
It was hard to stick through it.
Like I didn't want to stick through
it. I just wanted to, I'm like,
I'm just going to have a fucking apple
and a bowl of pasta and blow this died
off. But um, if you get through it,
then you feel your body switch over
when you feel you bought a switch over,
what happens is, um, you have more
even energy throughout the day.
Um, uh, less tired, no crash
in the middle of the day.
But I do have to say it took a long time
before my workouts felt like I could
have the same intensity.
I would die off quicker.
And as how I look at even some of
those, um, what do you call it?
Intermittent died things to them
and fasting. Yeah. Fasting. Yeah.
Like the w when you're drying out and
you're not eating and that period,
I wouldn't recommend
working out at that time.
Power lifting or a strength training.
Yeah.
I think that's a different kind of
animal. Yeah. Cause now you're getting,
carrying down the muscles and everything
else. Maybe some cardio wouldn't hurt.
Listen, I'm not, that's why I'm saying
I'm not knocking all of them. And I,
and my brother in law,
he,
the doctor told them they think that's
what it was from now granted that could
be because he messed up on
a diet somewhere along the
line, you know, um, meeting,
uh,
I had a doctor that,
a buddy also that got fatty liver from
eating too much of the meat. Again,
that could have been grass fed or steroid
type meat makes a difference. That was,
what the fuck.
I don't even know if that
does cause it does. Yeah.
And me personally,
I'm not knocking any of it cause her
pretty soon I've got to try some shit
myself, you know what I mean? Um,
I got to start losing weight again.
Well why did you start eating like crazy?
Because of the power lifting.
Yeah. Those guys. Yeah,
he like fucking savages and notary also
coming out to like where you can eat
right. Lose weight and still be
strong, you know, um, me, uh,
I started eating like that and then it
really, I'll tell you where it gets me.
So I was never a real big sweet
tooth, sweet tooth theater. Ah,
I is a piece of cake
or a candy bar and her,
I'd have like total throughout
the day and one count of pop.
I drank a half a can in a
morning or an afternoon.
Then at night for people who
didn't grow up in Ohio. Oh yeah.
That was soda, Coca Cola,
Pepsi, you know, sorry,
you'll pop Guy Columbus,
Ohio in the house. Yes.
And uh, that's right. Yeah,
we were talking about that
and that's what I would do.
So it wasn't that bad, but it's still
enough sugar, long fucking sugar.
And then I was starting the one meat,
I was doing a to 20 pound weight class,
I was two 32 and my guy was like,
you ain't gonna make it in six days to
get down to two to 20 and that kind of
like, I get a chuckle at that
because I had to make 160 before,
so I got all this fat sitting on me.
You're going to tell me I can't
lose that in six days. A bet.
And this is for a power lifting.
Yeah.
So I got down with that and
that was doing a wash. What?
I didn't even do hardly any cardio for
that and I still got down fairly easy to,
to 20 then now we're on falling into this
bad habit is I'll have like a piece of
cheesecake sitting in a refrigerator.
Okay. I know. And I love cheesecake.
And that's true. That's one of my
favorites. It's a good one, eh?
Would it be two cans
of pop left and right?
And my whole thing is I can't start.
I can't start watching cause
I don't want to say diet.
I started saying watching what I
eat and I go, I can't do that too.
When it's gone. I can't have that. I
know. It's weird. I'm telling you I can't,
I can't start until it's gone.
But you can't throw it away.
Can I can't throw it away,
throw it away because it's the only one
piece left and I don't want to do that.
So, and then the next thing I know my
sister in law who was a hell of a baker,
she makes something for the kids or
it makes me a homemade cheese cake.
And the next thing I know I'm
back into the same thing again.
Now let me tell you something
else that contributes to this.
I think all the years of of fighting
and having to watch my weight and
especially for me to get done in one 60
and even when I was fighting at 47 and
the amateurs I, my life was pretty much
running and it was a job, you know,
it was time somebody was there.
I just couldn't go run.
I had to run it so fast and I was
being timed for it and distance.
I had to watch what I was eating.
I had people over me watching what I was
eating and when I retired I was like,
fuck this man, I'm free. Right.
You know what I mean? And I,
I sometimes put that in the
back of my head, I shouldn't,
but I put in the back of my head
like, man, you deserve this man.
You did that all these years like,
but now it's coming to the point to
like you are getting a little older,
you look a little bit like
shit other than your arms.
Like you're going to have to start it
in a treadmill. You know what I mean?
It's one of those type things where if
you just cut the sugar out, but yeah,
and it works and I don't want to hear
people say that they can't lose weight now
that will only work for a certain period
of time until that like levels out.
Then you guys,
that's when you start tweaking the calorie
intake and then you can lose a lot of
weight if you just cut out the sugar.
Yeah, you can. Yeah. So that's why,
I mean I don't want to hear
people say it's hard. So I
will, I'll be eventually, I,
you know,
I said when I get home from this trip,
because like last night I went
out with my buddy and we ate uh,
pizzas and stuff like that.
So you know, cause I'm Ma,
I don't have the access
to healthy food right now.
While you're on the road places in La,
you can eat healthy. I know there is,
dare you, I dare you say you can't eat
healthy here as the mindset men. I know.
Yeah. The mindset. But that's, you know,
the thing about a lot of great fighters
is they're very impulsive too. Yeah.
It's just that fuck it.
Fuck it.
Mentality that sometimes carries over
to eating. Look at a lot of your ad guy.
Retired fighters. Yeah. They
get mean. They balloon up
and blow up. You know, again,
I keep saying, I'm not like
bragging or anything, but here I'm,
I'm fairly decent. You know what I mean?
I think at least you enjoy working out.
I think some guys,
they got to a point where they worked
out so hard for camps that when it's over
they don't want to do shit. Yeah. It
just like I'm done. It's over. No desire,
no drive. Well that's why cardio's
very rare for me. Right. Yeah. And uh,
you know, I used to say this
to all the time after a fight,
I have probably two or
three weeks off and I,
there was a place called Mill Creek
Park and a lot of people go to run and
exercise and stuff like that.
And there's a main street that goes past
the park and you see people riding a
bike and running. And I'll never forget,
my wife actually started laughing.
I just got done with a fight and we're
driving past Mule Creek Park and these
people were out running.
And I go, what idiots
like who gets up and go run? And I
left for, chances are I'm hilarious.
Chances are I,
if I didn't have to do it like that,
I didn't have somebody hounding
me or over me while I was running.
Chances are I would actually like running
and I would like doing cardio and add
that into my training.
But because it was a job for
all the mirrors from nine
years old to 30 years old,
it was like,
screw this man.
I don't want to run to run as if there
was a fire or a big ass dog behind me.
You know? That's the only way. Or if
I want to run to the buffet table,
but I know some people do it every day,
every day before work and they'll put
in five, six miles every day. And it,
you know what,
in this reality you have to,
you got to any more or less you would want
to be out of shape and, and miserable.
I think it's great to actually start
working out and even for me as I'm lifting
weights and it's fun and it's
considered exercising, but, um,
and now with what I'm thinking
of doing and everything else,
I got to start getting into that.
You know,
I'm hitting the bag and everything's
fun and I'm hitting the pads and that's
cardio. I mean that shit,
that shit's really cardio.
And now to run a really thinking
about finding and you're,
you said more than 60%,
right?
80% I would say around
70 to 80. That's a lot.
That is, that is. But again,
and I'll shrine going to see you this,
um,
there was a lot of that goes behind a
lot more to think about also, you know,
so I don't want, because what I don't
want is in six months when I say,
you know what? No, I don't
want the backlash for it.
He's walked up again and he knows.
And that's unfortunately,
that's the way it goes. It does. But
you got to not read that shit. I know,
but that's unfortunately, it really
is. Especially comments, you know,
I tried not to and you catch them and
you get them. I try not to. I, it's,
it seems like the boxing world in
particular has a lot of fucking haters,
but you know what, it's nothing like
football, like of a fighter loses.
I was was watching Barstool
sports, barstool sports, Instagram.
They got some fucking guy leaving a
football game screaming and yelling.
I'm like, this guy is what I think
about when I think of like Douche Stout,
like sports fans.
This guy fucking screaming about
somebody not being able to make it kick.
You know what I'm talking about? Yeah,
go ahead and crazy. It's so funny.
I love it. I love it. I love it.
I love hearing when I was playing
football and when I was in high school,
when you're watching these big games and
you'll see it on social or I'd be at a
buddy's house and I see have I
would've made that yet. Right.
People love saying stupid shit like that.
Like how many times did anybody given you
boxing advice? Oh, I have people that,
I don't know the difference between
a left Toke and efficient book.
I swear to God they don't.
And why didn't you just hit him?
Because he should have got up and
hit him in his TMZ. It material. No,
but I mean like, like they're
saying to you, why didn't,
why didn't you just hit him?
I don't know.
You don't have I seen the
episode that was the funniest.
I think it was on one of your episodes
with Charlie Murphy and they are doing
the Mike Tyson and like
de la Hoya situation that
happened like the guys that he
could beat up the lawyer and I true.
I wish I could happen on a regular basis,
you know like call people out on it
when you're in front of somebody. Yeah.
How many times I hear people say
like I, I could, I couldn't beat him.
And it's like, why? Why is he
sitting on like $25 million?
And you're over here picking up ups
shipments, you know what I mean?
Like there's a difference for a reason.
Nobody's knocking what you do,
but you shouldn't knock what he's
doing. Well, you're delusional. You are.
People are dilution.
But for whatever reason,
especially when it comes to
sports and fighting in particular,
people just say some
unbelievably delusional shit.
I don't know why and I truly
don't and I don't understand it.
And I'd never get into the argument long
enough to even ask the question. Well,
what was the last time you
went on somebody else's
page and commenting on shit,
I can't tell you cause you're a world
champion and I don't want to ask another
reason. Hey, let's, you
know what, that's funny too,
because how many of might want to write
how many of the threads in it and may
involve me? Because you know, again,
a reason why I have to stay up on it
is because that's part of my podcasts.
You know, we're through the social media,
so I have to, and he's boxing groups or
even on our own fight or a punchline,
a box and group.
You see the comments and
I'm just going and I'm like,
I can't really answer that though because
I look corny as shit if I answered
that one. You know? And so it's hard
and it's frustrating. It really is.
Well, the, the interesting world
that we live in today, I mean,
it's a great time to communicate
with people. It's amazing. No,
it's also a great time for
Douche bags to communicate.
It is dangerous time actually.
But I think it's cool that you're
doing this podcast thing and, uh,
I think it's awesome and I really do
hope you do commentary as far as you
fighting. Hey Man, if you find a watch,
but if you don't fight, I'll be happy to.
I'll definitely keep you in
the loop. Tell me. I know.
I will definitely keep you in the loop
coming down. If you do announce something,
something's happening,
I will do.
Let us know and tell people how
to get ahold of your podcast.
How can they get my podcast
is the punchline. Dot Live.
That's the easiest way to get
to it. Or on Youtube. Also,
you go to punchline what Kelly
Pavlick and James Domingez and uh,
we're on also on social media on
Tuesdays at seven o'clock eastern time.
So those are easy ways. Is it
on Itunes as well? No, no, no.
And that's where we're trying to go with
your couch shit on iTunes. Jesus Christ.
Hey listen, I'm learning. Um, yeah,
but yeah, punchline.live. And then,
you know,
you go to youtube,
the punchline with Kelly public
and James Domingez and, uh,
that's the way to get to it. Well, thanks
for doing this, brother. Hey, my pleasure.
I truly Joe's it was awesome, man. I
appreciate it, man. Fun Times. Yup.
Kelly Pavlik Ladies and gentlemen,
that was two hours.